programming throwdown episode 71 office spaces take it away jason hey everyone uh so halloween is approaching and one of the things we gotta do for halloween is get our wi-fi set up sure worst segue ever so i wanted to tell everyone about my wi-fi setup because i think it's pretty cool a lot of people don't um really take the time to kind of set up something, but it can really make your life a lot easier. So yeah, so what I have, I actually have, you know, the modem connected to a wireless router. The wireless router can do the 2.4 gigahertz, but it could also do the five gigahertz it's like the dual band router and then i have an extender which is you know on the other end of the house or about halfway through the house and so the extender allows us to like extend the internet so in other words if we didn't have the extender then it just happens that the cable company put our you know cable
Programming Throwdown 第71期，办公空间，Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，万圣节快到了，我们得做的一件事就是把 Wi-Fi 设置好。当然，这是有史以来最烂的过渡。所以我想告诉大家我的 Wi-Fi 设置，因为我觉得它很酷。很多人并没有花时间去设置它，但它确实能让你的生活轻松很多。所以，是的，我现在的设置是，调制解调器连接到一个无线路由器。这个无线路由器既支持 2.4 GHz，也支持 5 GHz，它是一个双频路由器。然后我还有一个扩展器，放在房子的另一端，或者说房子的中间位置，这个扩展器可以让我们扩展网络。换句话说，如果我们没有这个扩展器，恰好有线电视公司把我们的电缆
modem on the far side of the house and so we don't have internet on the other side without this extender right so that's pretty standard but the part that's really cool I installed this thing called DDWRT and I highly recommend before you buy your wireless router that you go on the website DDWRT, and I highly recommend before you buy your wireless router that you go on the website, DDWRT, I think,.com, and make sure that your router is compatible with this. Even if you don't plan on doing it right away, it's just good to have that capability, right? And so some of the things that it does, you can actually assign domain names to MAC addresses. So Jason, one second. So the idea of DDWRT is it's a replacement firmware.
调制解调器放在了房子的最远端，如果没有这个扩展器，我们在房子的另一边就没法上网了。所以这很标准，但真正酷的部分是我安装了一个叫 DD-WRT 的东西。我强烈建议你在购买无线路由器之前，先去 DD-WRT 的网站看看，我强烈建议你在购买无线路由器之前，先去 DD-WRT 的网站，我想是 .com，确保你的路由器与它兼容。即使你不打算马上安装，拥有这种能力也是件好事，对吧？它能做的一些事情包括，你可以为 MAC 地址分配域名。等等，Jason，等一下。所以 DD-WRT 的概念是它是一个替代固件。
So instead of the firmware your router ships with, you install essentially a different operating system for the router. So a different firmware made by different people than what your router came with. And it unlocks extra capabilities. Yeah, exactly. So basically, I think it's a version of Linux or something. what your router came with and it unlocks extra capabilities yeah that yeah exactly so basically it's i think it's a version of linux or something i don't know the details but uh yeah imagine it's
所以，与其使用路由器自带的固件，你实际上是为路由器安装了一个不同的操作系统。也就是由不同的人制作的、不同于路由器原厂的固件。它解锁了额外的功能。是的，完全正确。所以基本上，我认为它是 Linux 的一个版本之类的。它解锁了额外的功能，是的，完全正确。所以基本上，我想它是 Linux 的一个版本之类的，我不知道细节，但想象一下它是
like you know installing you know ubuntu on your desktop instead of windows it's going to change you know basically everything um but one of the things it has, which my router didn't have the capability of, is you can say this MAC address should have this name. So, for example, my desktop has the name GNOME, G-N-O-M-E. And my laptop has a different name. My work laptop has a different name. And so if I want to connect to my desktop and I'm at home, I can just type, you know, SSH gnome. Or because, you know, I have my own domain name, I can type SSH gnome dot, you know, my domain name. And it will connect. And so even if my desktop has a different IP address, it doesn't matter. I can just connect to gnome.
像在你的桌面上安装 Ubuntu 而不是 Windows 一样，它基本上会改变一切。但它有一个功能，我的路由器原本没有，那就是你可以指定这个 MAC 地址应该有这个名字。例如，我的台式机名字叫 GNOME，G-N-O-M-E。我的笔记本电脑有不同的名字。我的工作笔记本电脑也有不同的名字。所以如果我在家想连接到我的台式机，我只需要输入 SSH gnome。或者因为我有自己的域名，我可以输入 SSH gnome.我的域名。它就会连接。所以即使我的台式机有不同的 IP 地址也没关系，我可以直接连接到 gnome。
And so even like the Raspberry Pi is called Pi, you know, everything is just on a name basis. The other thing I have is I have what's called a bunch of port forwarding. So I can actually SSH to gnome.mydomainname, even if I'm somewhere else, like even if I'm in another country. And it'll actually go to that domain name, which will send the SSH command to my house, and then my router will send that command to GNOME. So I could do SSH GNOME from my house, I could do it from someone else's house, and it just works. And so that's DNS mask is the part of DWRT that does that. The other thing that's pretty cool, it has per MAC address bandwidth.
甚至像树莓派（Raspberry Pi）也被称为 Pi，一切都是基于名字的。我还有另一个功能，就是所谓的端口转发。所以我甚至可以在别的地方，比如在另一个国家，SSH 到 gnome.mydomainname。它会连接到那个域名，然后把 SSH 命令发送到我家，我的路由器再把命令发送给 GNOME。所以我可以在我家 SSH 到 GNOME，也可以在别人家里做，它都能正常工作。这就是 DD-WRT 中 DNSMasq 的功能。另一个很酷的功能是，它有基于 MAC 地址的带宽限制。
So, you know, have you ever had this happen where one of the computers in the house starts updating? Like someone else in your family maybe, you know, or maybe they're watching a really high def video. Or, you know, the computer is downloading some large update. And it kind of slows everybody else down. Like everyone else, the video starts stuttering, or if you're playing a game, it starts jittering or something like that. So I have like per MAC address bandwidth cap. So even if it's downloading some update,
所以，你有没有遇到过这种情况：家里的某台电脑开始更新？比如你的家人，或者他们正在看高清视频。或者电脑正在下载某个大型更新。它会拖慢其他所有人的速度。比如其他人的视频开始卡顿，或者如果你在玩游戏，它会开始抖动之类的。所以我设置了基于 MAC 地址的带宽上限。所以即使它在下载更新，
and even if Microsoft on the other end has just unlimited bandwidth, it's not going to download it more than, I don't know what I have it set to, maybe a mega second or something. And so that's going to make sure that one computer isn't starving everybody else. So yeah, that's kind of my setup. I'm really digging it.
即使微软那边的带宽是无限的，它也不会下载得超过——我不知道我设置的是多少，也许是每秒 1 兆之类的。这样就能确保一台电脑不会占用所有人的带宽。所以，这就是我的设置，我真的很喜欢。
I had it issued today and I was able to resolve it using our tool of the show. so a little foreshadowing but in general you know having a DWRT makes life kind of way easier and you know I highly recommend it and it works kind of really well with you know Plex and some of these other things that we've talked about in the past anything where you're kind of using your own network, right? Very cool. I've been using OpenWRT and DDWRT, which I won't get into the political banter. I actually don't know the difference, yeah.
我今天遇到了一个问题，通过我们节目的工具解决了它。所以这算是一个小小的预告，但总的来说，使用 DD-WRT 让生活变得轻松多了，我强烈推荐它。它和 Plex 以及我们过去谈到过的其他东西配合得非常好，任何你需要使用自己网络的地方，对吧？太酷了。我一直在用 OpenWRT 和 DD-WRT，我不想卷入政治争论。我其实不知道它们的区别，是的。
Okay. I think OpenWRT is a little harder to use, but the more open source sort of spirit one. Oh, okay. And they've come a long way. I don't know. I haven't used OpenW wrt in a while so when i used to use it the so dd wrt has a really nice uh user interface a web gui uh and when i
好的。我觉得 OpenWRT 用起来稍微难一点，但它更有开源精神。哦，好的。而且它们已经进步了很多。我不知道，我已经很久没用 OpenWRT 了，所以我以前用它的时候，DD-WRT 有一个非常好的用户界面，一个 Web GUI，当我
last used it which probably was more than five years ago open wrt didn't um but i probably used some combination of the two for seven eight years maybe even more maybe 10 years um so for a long time and i am by no means a networking person uh so doing the things jason said so you know doing static ips for certain mac addresses naming things doing qos filtering so that you know http traffic is given preference over bit torrent traffic um which i never have on my network um and right of course well you have bit torrent sync right that was one of our tools of the show yes and i think also um not steam but some other stuff uses bit torrent uh for updating stuff. Yeah, Blizzard. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
最后一次使用它时，那大概是五年前的事了，OpenWRT 当时还没有。但我可能在七八年，甚至十年里混合使用过它们。所以我对网络并不精通，所以做 Jason 说的那些事，比如为特定的 MAC 地址设置静态 IP，命名设备，进行 QoS 过滤，让 HTTP 流量优先于 BitTorrent 流量——我网络里从不跑 BitTorrent——当然，你有 BitTorrent Sync，对吧？那是我们节目的工具之一。是的，而且我想除了 Steam，还有其他一些东西在更新时也会使用 BitTorrent。是的，暴雪。是的，是的，是的。
The Blizzard games. Yeah. And then recently, though, I gave up my last DDWRT router and went enterprise grade. And this is going to sound like total shill, but I bought Ubiquiti enterprise grade networking hardware. How much did that cost? It turns out not as expensive as you might think hearing the words enterprise-grade networking hardware. So, you know, sort of mid-range to, like, pretty good consumer router
暴雪游戏。是的。不过最近，我放弃了最后一个 DD-WRT 路由器，换成了企业级的。这听起来可能像是在打广告，但我买了 Ubiquiti 的企业级网络硬件。那花了多少钱？事实证明，并没有你听到“企业级网络硬件”时想象的那么贵。所以，这大概是中端到相当不错的家用路由器，
probably costs, like, $100 to $150. Okay. And so Ubiquiti comes sort of piecemeal so instead of like jason was describing like a router and a wireless access point built into one um the enterprise stuff is more split apart and this isn't true you know enterprise enterprise grade although it can be but this is sort of the lower end like entry level almost like with uh digital slrs that the kind of prosumer so it's both people who are professional enterprise,
可能花费 100 到 150 美元。好的。Ubiquiti 的产品是零散的，所以不像 Jason 描述的那样，路由器和无线接入点合二为一。企业级的东西更分散，虽然这不完全是真正的企业级，但它属于低端入门级，就像数码单反相机里的“准专业级”一样，所以它既适合专业企业，
but also people who are just want really good hardware for their house. Is it huge? Or like, what does it look like? No, so it's pretty small, but it comes piecemeal. So I have a router
也适合那些只想为家里买好硬件的人。它很大吗？或者它看起来是什么样的？不，它很小，但它是零散的。所以我有一个路由器，
that has no wireless capabilities and then a single wireless access point. But the coverage on it is so much better than i was getting from my normal just sort of like asus router that i had before and part of that is because even with the wrt you could increase the power of your router increasing the power of the router helps for your cell phone for instance to be able to hear the router but it doesn't help the router be able to hear your phone so that makes sense increasing power actually can help in some limited circumstances but not in all of them so having
它没有无线功能，然后有一个单独的无线接入点。但它的覆盖范围比我之前用的华硕路由器好得多。部分原因是，即使使用 WRT，你也可以增加路由器的功率。增加功率有助于你的手机接收到路由器的信号，但并不能帮助路由器接收到手机的信号，所以这说得通。增加功率在某些有限的情况下确实有帮助，但并非总是如此。所以拥有
you know big antennas helps and stuff too um and the some of the nicer things have that but you know sort of boosting power doesn't actually advantage you as much as you, as I naively sort of thought. But the antennas in this Ubiquiti hardware are much better. And there are several other brands that do this sort of enterprise
大天线也有帮助，一些更好的设备确实有这些。但提升功率实际上并没有你——或者像我天真地认为的那样——有那么大的优势。但这些 Ubiquiti 硬件里的天线要好得多。还有其他几个品牌也做这种企业级
slash prosumer stuff. But I think it ended up being, I think it's sort of like $50 for the router I got and like $100, $110 for the access point so like 160 so most people probably at all probably don't spend that much money on their you know router but people who pay a lot of attention might um i mean i actually i bought a neck gear and i spent probably close to the same thing and i got i, it was definitely like a high-end NIC year.
或准专业级的东西。但我认为最终算下来，路由器大概 50 美元，接入点大概 100 到 110 美元，总共 160 美元左右。大多数人可能不会在路由器上花那么多钱，但那些非常关注网络的人可能会。其实我买了一个网件（Netgear），花的钱也差不多，那绝对是一个高端的网件。
That's one thing we should mention, actually. Spend a lot of money on a router. Because a lot of these access points, they're totally starved for memory. You get this access point, it tries to run Linux on a gig of RAM or something. And it's also trying to do all this other stuff, right? So just spend the extra money and get, you know, like a nice router that has four or eight gigs of RAM. It's going to make a huge difference.
有一点我们应该提一下，在路由器上多花点钱。因为很多接入点的内存完全不足。你买了这个接入点，它试图在 1GB 内存上运行 Linux 之类的。而且它还在尝试做所有其他事情，对吧？所以多花点钱买一个有 4GB 或 8GB 内存的好路由器，会有巨大的差别。
Yeah. So this enterprise stuff, though, is super awesome in that, like, it's been rock solid. So since I've installed, I've never had to bounce power on my system. And it's been a couple months now and before you know i got the ddwrt style stuff i got to the point where i'd only have to reset it like once a month before that i guess i have a lot of wireless devices in my house so it was tending to be like once a week or whatever yeah i basically in the same but i mean
是的。不过这些企业级的东西非常棒，因为它非常稳定。自从安装以来，我从来不需要重启系统。已经几个月了，而在我使用 DD-WRT 风格的设备之前，我每个月都得重启一次。在那之前，我想因为我家里有很多无线设备，所以大概每周都要重启一次。是的，我基本也一样，但我买的是
i bought uh the netgear one and i have to cycle power on it i actually don't even really have to but you can kind of feel it start to degrade a little bit um but it's it's it's about every maybe three or four months yeah so so far this new style i switched recently but i will say it one thing it made me realize is how little i understand about networking so same here on the consumer hard and i've also heard good things about the new mesh routers that have been starting to roll out apparently they didn't used to be so good but jason like he was saying has a wi-fi extender now i think google ships one some other one erio or something there's a couple oh yeah right um where
网件的，我确实需要重启它。其实我甚至不需要重启，但你能感觉到它开始有点变慢了。大概每三四个月一次吧。是的，到目前为止，这种我最近换的新风格很稳定。但有一点让我意识到，我对网络了解得太少了。我也是，在消费级硬件上。我也听说过最近开始推出的新网状（Mesh）路由器，据说以前它们没那么好，但像 Jason 刚才说的，他现在有一个 Wi-Fi 扩展器。我想谷歌出了一款，还有 Eero 之类的，有几款。哦，是的，对。
one connects to your actual modem, and then you have other devices which connect to that device, doing exactly what Jason said, only they sort of, what Jason has probably is, I don't mean this insult, but kind of a dumb thing. It just acts as a client, but it doesn't sort of cooperatively do anything with the home, the thing that's connected to his modem.
其中一个连接到你的调制解调器，然后你有其他设备连接到那个设备，做的正是 Jason 说的那些事。只是它们，我不是想冒犯，但 Jason 的那个有点“笨”。它只是作为一个客户端，并没有与连接到调制解调器的主设备进行协作。
These other ones, these mesh ones are supposed to do sort of more automatic configuration with each other to not interfere yeah like i have to manually take all my mobile devices and put them on the extender which is in the middle of the house and just hope that that's the best situation for them because if you had a mesh network they would actually seamlessly go from one to the other yep so um i've heard good things about those so apparently it's all around just getting better but the consumer stuff hides a lot of choices for you when you go to this other you know i did a bunch of reading kind of configured the scrape the bare surface of the options but apparently i thought i was you know kind of hot stuff by knowing how to explore the advanced settings in my DDWRT router.
这些网状路由器据说能进行更自动化的配置，互不干扰。是的，我必须手动把所有的移动设备连接到房子中间的扩展器上，只能祈祷那是它们最好的连接点。因为如果你有网状网络，它们会自动无缝地从一个切换到另一个。是的，所以我听说过这些东西的好处。看来一切都在变得更好，但消费级产品为你隐藏了很多选择。当我深入研究这些时，我配置了一下，只触及了选项的皮毛。我本以为自己很厉害，因为我知道如何探索 DD-WRT 路由器里的高级设置。
It turned out, no, those weren't advanced settings. I mean, they were for it. But when I got this new hardware, the number of things in there that I didn't even understand was astronomically high. So in the Ubiquiti one, I mean, are you in there like modifying IP tables on the command line or does it have a decent interface? So both. You can do everything
结果发现，不，那些根本不是高级设置。我是说，对那个路由器来说是。但当我拿到这个新硬件时，里面我不懂的东西多得惊人。那么在 Ubiquiti 的设备里，你是通过命令行修改 IP 表，还是它有一个不错的界面？两者都有。你可以做所有事情，
sort of from the command line because it's meant for people who need to go install, you know, dozens of these in one building. Oh, I see. And manage it remotely and all sorts of stuff.
从命令行操作，因为它是为那些需要在同一栋楼里安装几十个设备的人准备的。哦，我明白了。而且可以远程管理，等等。
But they do actually have they have enough of a web UI and it is intuitive enough to kind of get you through what you need to do. So I was able to get everything I needed to done. But it has all sorts of kind of nice features. Like I had put black electrical tape over the lights on my previous router. Yeah, I have that too. On these ones, they have an option where you just click a button
但他们确实有足够的 Web UI，而且足够直观，可以引导你完成需要做的事情。所以我能够完成所有我需要做的事。它还有各种不错的功能。比如我以前在旧路由器的灯上贴了黑色电胶带。是的，我也有。在这些设备上，它们有一个选项，你只需点击一个按钮，
and it turns all the lights off. Oh, that's nice. Which sounds really stupid, really stupid but it's like oh that's so nice no it is because i mean yeah ours is right next to the tv and it's just constantly blinking right so um anyways i this is not a pitch for ubiquity so i'm really enjoying it myself but do be aware like yeah it i'm sure if something went really bad it it would take you know that much longer for you to figure out how to fix it but the idea is it shouldn't go bad because you're not really supposed to mess around with it yeah yeah it totally makes sense at least and it probably lets you back up the config yeah it does and then i know things like recently there was some problems
就能关掉所有的灯。哦，那太好了。这听起来很傻，真的很傻，但你会觉得“哦，那太棒了”。不，确实很棒，因为我们的路由器就在电视旁边，灯一直在闪。总之，这不是在为 Ubiquiti 做广告，我只是自己用得很开心。但要注意，如果出了大问题，你可能需要花更长的时间去弄清楚怎么修复。但它的理念是，它不应该出问题，因为你不需要去乱动它。是的，这完全说得通。而且它可能允许你备份配置。是的，可以。而且我知道最近有一些问题，
and they're really good about pushing updates because they have corporate clients who are very concerned about security and stuff. So a lot of the consumer routers, people just sort of never update their firmware. So they don't really bother pushing updates to firmware that often. But with this Ubiquiti stuff, it's actually fairly frequent in kind of updating this stuff. Oh, that's great. So the support is good. Very cool.
他们非常擅长推送更新，因为他们有非常关心安全问题的企业客户。很多消费级路由器的用户从来不更新固件。所以厂商也不太费心去推送固件更新。但对于 Ubiquiti 的产品，更新相当频繁。哦，那太好了。所以支持很好。太酷了。
Yeah. And if you use our tool of the show my tool of the show which i'm not going to spoil it yet but uh wow that's he'll actually tell you your your wi-fi status like your signal strength and everything um all right on to news so um this interesting thing it only affects california but uh it was interesting enough i figured i would bring it up there's a law in california now employers are banned from asking your prior salary. So in other words, you go to a job interview, they really like you, they say, hey, we want to make you an offer. They're not allowed to ask you what you made before. And the reason why they passed this law is it's a two-part reason.
是的。如果你使用我们节目的工具——我的工具，我还没打算剧透——它会告诉你 Wi-Fi 的状态，比如信号强度等等。好了，进入新闻环节。这个有趣的事情只影响加利福尼亚州，但它很有趣，所以我决定提一下。加州现在有一项法律，禁止雇主询问你的过往薪资。换句话说，你去面试，他们很喜欢你，他们说：“嘿，我们想给你发 Offer。”他们不允许问你以前赚多少钱。他们通过这项法律的原因有两部分。
The first part is people tend to not know how to negotiate. We did talk about negotiating in the past. So check out Negotiating for Dummies is the book I recommend. But pick up any book on negotiating. It'll teach you a lot. A lot of people don't know how to negotiate. One of the big things is not to really just spill all your guts right away. If you just, you know, let's say they were planning on paying you, you know, $30 an hour. And so that's sort of what they have in their mind. And
第一部分是人们往往不知道如何谈判。我们过去谈过谈判。所以去看看《Negotiating for Dummies》这本书，我推荐它。或者随便找一本关于谈判的书，它会教你很多。很多人不知道如何谈判。其中一件大事就是不要一开始就全盘托出。假设他们原本打算付给你每小时 30 美元，这是他们心里的预期。然后
they think, well, we're going to lowball this person, we're going to offer them $25 an hour. So maybe that's their strategy you know the potential company strategy going in and you go and say hey you know my last job i made eight dollars an hour doing the same thing well they're going to use that information they say oh well we're going to try we're going to you know uh ask 12 an hour and this person's going to be a stat it's a 50 increase uh and what you don't know as the applicant is, is that, you know, they were willing to offer you, you know, whatever I said the first time, 25 or whatever it was. So a lot of people sort of like self injure themselves by, uh, giving away their prior salary. Um, and, and, uh, uh, particularly from the studies that they did they found that women tend to do
他们想：“好吧，我们要压低这个人的薪水，我们给他们每小时 25 美元。”也许这就是他们进入谈判的策略。然后你去说：“嘿，我上一份工作做同样的事情，每小时赚 8 美元。”好吧，他们会利用这些信息，说：“哦，那我们试着给 12 美元吧。”这对这个人来说是 50% 的涨幅。而作为申请人，你不知道的是，他们原本愿意给你我刚才说的那个数字，25 美元或者其他什么。所以很多人通过泄露过往薪资来“自残”。而且，根据他们的研究，他们发现女性往往比男性
this much more than men um so so in the in the theme of sort of trying to close the uh you know the the gender wage gap and all of that um they pass this law so the idea is it kind of evens a playing field uh you know it prevents everybody from making that mistake. And so it's kind of interesting. I mean, I think it's one of these things that like, you know, on the surface, like the way I just explained it, it sounds very obvious, right? What's not obvious is sort of how that's really going to change the dynamics, right? You know, I don't really know sort of like what the actual implication of that is um in terms of like you know i guess the company will not ask you some people will probably say it anyways um but a lot more people aren't going to say which means there's going to be this sort of
更容易这样做。所以，为了缩小性别薪酬差距，他们通过了这项法律。这个想法是，它拉平了竞争环境，防止每个人犯同样的错误。这很有趣。我的意思是，我认为这属于那种表面上看，就像我刚才解释的那样，听起来很明显的事情。不明显的是它将如何真正改变动态。我真的不知道这在实际中意味着什么。我想公司不会问你，有些人可能还是会说，但更多的人不会说，这意味着会出现一种
baseline my guess is a lot of companies are going to start really low-balling people, which is basically going to force them to have to decline a really low offer, which is, I think, going to actually hurt women twice as much as they're being hurt already. So I actually think it's going to completely backfire because what companies are going to do is they're going to say, hey, you know, come for $4 an hour and, you know, because they're not going to have any information, is they're going to say hey you know come for four dollars an hour and uh you know because they're not gonna have any information so they're gonna assume really low and uh we'll have to see sort of who takes that and who negotiates and but yeah i found this really interesting because again i'm super into game theory and all of that lately and this fits right in in my wheelhouse so um yeah we'll see what happens i feel like we
基准。我的猜测是，很多公司会开始大幅压低薪资，这基本上会迫使人们不得不拒绝一份很低的 Offer。我认为这实际上会给女性带来双重伤害。所以我认为这会完全适得其反，因为公司会说：“嘿，来吧，每小时 4 美元。”因为他们没有任何信息，他们会假设一个很低的数字。我们将看看谁会接受，谁会谈判。但我发现这很有趣，因为我最近对博弈论非常感兴趣，这正中我的下怀。所以，我们走着瞧。我觉得我们
should write that down jason claims it'll backfire do you have a date of when it'll backfire by no well it's one of these things we'll never really know because you know so much of this it's also is private yeah that's true it's also very difficult because it's really tough you want to help but it isn't clear how to help and right that if someone makes if someone is sort of consistently low-balled at every job they sort of can fall farther and farther behind what they should be making if you sort of carry their salaries forward but like you said simply not revealing it doesn't prevent them from accidentally getting a low ball offer and not accidentally,
应该记下来，Jason 声称这会适得其反。你有它什么时候会适得其反的日期吗？不，这属于那种我们永远不会真正知道的事情，因为很多东西都是私密的。是的，那倒是。这也很困难，因为你想帮忙，但不清楚该怎么帮。如果一个人在每份工作中都被持续压低薪资，如果把薪资带入下一份工作，他们可能会落后得越来越远。但就像你说的，仅仅不透露它，并不能防止他们意外地得到一份低薪 Offer，不是意外，
but getting a low ball offer and then accepting without realizing they didn't need to accept one that low. Exactly. Right. I mean, what you want is an English auction where somebody applies to, you know, eight companies and then they pick the highest offer. But, you know, that's not really practical. So, uh, so, you know, in the absence of that, there's always going to be sort of this, this gap, right? This is really tough, but I mean, it's good that it's getting consideration because I feel like culturally we have a far way to go before we get over a lot of the stigmas that hurt employees. Yeah, that's true. Actually. Yeah. Not to like spend too much time
而是得到一份低薪 Offer，然后没意识到他们不需要接受那么低的薪水就接受了。完全正确。我的意思是，你想要的是一种英式拍卖，某人申请八家公司，然后选择最高的 Offer。但这并不现实。所以，在没有这种情况的情况下，总会存在这种差距。这真的很棘手，但它得到关注是件好事，因为我觉得在文化上，我们还有很长的路要走，才能克服许多伤害员工的偏见。是的，那倒是。其实，不想花太多时间
on this but you know a lot of people are afraid of you know negotiating and pushing back um my two cents of this number one a company even if they say they'll take back an offer they'll never actually take back an offer i did no actually i did see that happen just recently what anecdotally this did happen but wait so is it okay i can see it happening if someone else like they have two candidates and the other person but that's usually pretty rare but so you're saying someone made an offer and then the company made an offer and then the person said i want you know x dollars more and then the other company just rejected them no no so the story as i understand it was that basically the i think
在这上面，但很多人害怕谈判和反击。关于这一点，我的两点看法：第一，公司即使说他们会撤回 Offer，他们也永远不会真的撤回。我没见过，其实我最近确实见过这种情况。真的吗？轶事证据，但这确实发生了。等等，所以，如果有人——他们有两个候选人，另一个人——但这通常很少见。所以你是说公司发了 Offer，然后那个人说“我想要多 X 美元”，然后公司就拒绝了他们？不，不，据我所知，故事是这样的：候选人试图这样做，但结果他们拖拖拉拉，所以 Offer 被撤回了。好吧，公平地说，那通常不会发生。
what the candidate was trying to do that but it just didn't end up that they were taking they were dragging their feet and so the author was withdrawn okay fair well i mean well that in general like that's you know uh that that doesn't happen very often um like it doesn't happen very often. It doesn't happen often enough to really consider it as part of your strategy. But yeah, I think. Oh, yeah. So I was gonna say, so basically, you know, you're negotiating with this recruiter, the recruiter wants you to take the job, and it's not the recruiter's money. Like, you know, if you get twice as much salary, it's not like the recruiter has to pay that out um the people who want to you know negotiate are actually the finance people at the company who you don't get a chance to really talk to right which is on purpose because if if you know you develop a relationship with the finance person that's like a huge liability for the company, so you purposely aren't exposed to those people. Um, and, uh, uh, yeah, I mean, and so, you know, and even the finance people, it's not their money either. Right. I mean, it is sort of, I guess, an aggregate, but, but for a specific case, it's not really their money either.
它发生的频率不足以让你将其作为策略的一部分。但我想，哦，是的。我想说的是，基本上你是在和招聘人员谈判，招聘人员希望你接受这份工作，而且那不是招聘人员的钱。如果你薪水翻倍，招聘人员并不需要支付这笔钱。真正想谈判的是公司里的财务人员，你根本没机会和他们交谈。这是故意的，因为如果你和财务人员建立了关系，这对公司来说是一个巨大的责任，所以你故意不会接触到这些人。而且，是的，即使是财务人员，那也不是他们的钱。对，我的意思是，这在总量上可能是，但对于具体案例，那确实不是他们的钱。
So, so people shouldn't be ashamed to say, look, like, I think I'm worth this, or I think I'm worth that. But, but you're right that it is kind of like a stigma. Most people feel like they are sort of telling the person on the other end of the line that that person doesn't know what they're talking about, or something like that. And that mostly applies to what Jason's talking about big companies. At big companies, the people doing the hiring are very far removed from sort of the source of the money. Like they're not really in any meaningful way financially impacted by the decision. I think all bets are probably off at small companies.
所以人们不应该羞于说：“看，我觉得我值这个价，或者我觉得我值那个价。”但你是对的，这确实有一种污名。大多数人觉得他们是在告诉电话那头的人，那个人不知道自己在说什么，或者类似的事情。这主要适用于 Jason 谈论的大公司。在大公司，负责招聘的人离资金来源非常遥远。他们并没有以任何有意义的方式在财务上受到这个决定的影响。我想在小公司，一切皆有可能。
Yeah, I've never actually worked at a small company. Have you? No. But I mean, I can imagine that. It's a different story, right? If you're talking to the owner of the company, negotiating a salary is probably a different conversation. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, you'd probably be talking straight to the stakeholder in that case. But either way, you know, I mean, the law has good intentions and we'll see what happens. I mean, just because I'm'm skeptical it doesn't mean i don't appreciate you know the intent uh my article is haskell type classes versus c++ classes and this is a i i guess a sort of highbrow article and i actually don't want to refer to it at all
是的，我从来没在小公司工作过。你呢？没有。但我可以想象，那是另一回事，对吧？如果你直接和公司老板谈，谈薪水可能是一场不同的对话。是的，那说得通。是的，在那种情况下，你可能是直接和利益相关者谈。但无论如何，法律有良好的初衷，我们走着瞧。仅仅因为我持怀疑态度，并不意味着我不欣赏这种意图。我的文章是《Haskell 类型类与 C++ 类》，这是一篇比较高深的文章，我其实根本不想引用它，
because of the haskell type classes so um although I'm sure the coverage of Haskell type classes is insightful and great, and I did read the part, not being a day-to-day Haskell programmer, it was sort of, meh, okay. And then there was a bunch of commentary. I actually picked this up from Hacker News, news.ycombinator. And there was conversation on there about sort of the right way to kind of do this in haskell but what i want to recommend this for is the first sort of half of the article covers sort of how classes work in c and c plus plus well how classes work in c plus plus and how you would implement them in c because once you implement them in C, you sort of directly understand kind of how they
因为 Haskell 类型类。虽然我相信关于 Haskell 类型类的报道很有见地，也很棒，我也读了一部分，但作为一个不是每天都写 Haskell 的程序员，感觉一般。然后还有一堆评论。我其实是从 Hacker News (news.ycombinator) 上看到的。上面有关于在 Haskell 中做这件事的正确方法的讨论。但我推荐这篇文章是因为它的前半部分涵盖了类在 C 和 C++ 中是如何工作的，特别是 C++，以及你如何在 C 中实现它们。因为一旦你在 C 中实现它们，你就直接理解了它们
would be implemented in assembly. And then you kind of know how classes work. Now, this is something that I think, well, a lot of people who program in C++ never sort of stop to take time to think about this. And most people wouldn't really know what a V table is or how it works or how it's laid out. And so I want to recommend this because I've never gotten looking for that information. So maybe there are better tutorials, but this one I felt that was a pretty good,
在汇编中是如何实现的。然后你就知道类是如何工作的了。这是我认为很多用 C++ 编程的人从来没有停下来思考过的问题。大多数人可能不知道什么是虚函数表（V-table），它是如何工作的，或者它是如何布局的。所以我推荐这篇文章，因为我从来没找到过那方面的信息。所以也许有更好的教程，但我感觉这一篇对该材料的呈现非常清晰。所以它从一些简单的例子开始，一步步讲解。
clear presentation of that material. So it sort of just starts with some simple examples and walks through. Yeah, that's cool. I didn't realize you could get the compiler to print out that information. I didn't actually. So Jason's saying that they actually show that there's a flag I didn't know about
是的，那很酷。我没意识到你可以让编译器打印出那些信息。我真的不知道。所以 Jason 是说他们展示了一个我不知道的标志，
that will get the compiler to show the V table for a class. Yeah, really cool. Anyways, so check it out because this is probably going to be horrible to try to describe over... Yeah, you have to just read it....over podcasts. But yeah, check it out. probably gonna be horrible to try to sort of describe over you have to just read it over um
可以让编译器显示类的虚函数表。是的，真的很酷。总之，去看看吧，因为这在播客里描述起来可能会很糟糕……是的，你必须亲自读一下……在播客里。但去看看吧，如果你写 C++，我是理解你的工具集在做什么的忠实粉丝。所以这包括理解 C++ 中类是如何布局内存的，这是一个很好的参考。太酷了。你有没有……好吧，我想这引出了下一个问题。你有没有……好吧，我想这引出了下一个问题。你有没有……你以前做过 C++ 编程。你有没有参加过面试，
podcast but yeah check it out if you're if you write in c++ i am a big fan of understanding what your tool set is doing and so part of that is getting an understanding of how memory is laid out for classes in c++ and this is a great reference for that very cool did you ever get oh well i guess this is leading to the next question Did you ever get, oh, well, I guess this is leading to the next question. Have you ever been, so you've done C++ programming before. Have you ever done an interview
要求你使用 C++ 作为首选语言？没有。我的意思是，有人问过我 C++ 的具体问题，但通常我都有选择权。那是真的吗？我刚才想收回，抱歉。有一次我面试，他们专门要求我用 C++ 编码。
where you did your language, preferred language as C++? No. I mean, I've had people ask me C++ specific questions, but usually I've been given the choice. And is that true i was just gonna take it back sorry one time i did an interview and they specifically asked me to code in c++
好的。但大多数时候，我面试时总是选 Python 或 Java 之类的。我只是好奇，因为我知道我以前被问过关于内部运作的详细问题。我从来不知道这是个好问题还是坏问题，但我会说这被认为是公平的。所以问“什么是虚函数表，它是如何工作的”，如果你是 C++ 程序员，你应该准备好如何回答。在 Java 中，我假设——我不是 Java 专家——但我想 Java 也有类似的东西，理解类型是如何工作的，以及这在内存管理上意味着什么。
okay um but yeah the majority of the time i always pick like python or java or something for just for interviews i'm just curious so i know i've been asked sort of detailed internal workings questions before i never know if it's a good question or a bad question but i will say it's considered fair game so to ask what is a v table how does it work if you're a c++ programmer you should sort of be prepared how to answer that and in java i assume, I'm not a Java expert at that level, but I think Java has a similar thing, understanding kind of how types work and what that sort of equates to for memory management.
即使你不必自己动手，理解它是如何发生的，我想这可能是公平的。是的，那说得通。是的，我倾向于遇到很多数据结构类型的问题，这就是为什么我总是选择 Python 或 Java。
Even though you don't have to do it yourself, understanding how it happens, I imagine is probably a fair game. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I mean, I tend to get a lot of like data structure type questions and things like that, which is why I always refer to like using Python or Java.
其实大多数时候，即使是 Java，也要看问题。但如果是某种需要构建数据结构的问题，Java 似乎是一个很容易使用的语言。但有一次有人让我做——我不记得了，好像是在 C++ 里构建一个加法器之类的。所以，Thomas 写信问——抱歉，我应该先说明一下，我们其实偏离了新闻，我要在这里回答一些问题。我们收到了很多非常有趣的问题，我们把它们作为开场话题，但如果我们根据问题的范围穿插回答，我们可以回答更多问题。
Actually, most of the time, even Java, depending on the question. But if it's some type of, yeah, like something where you have to build some data structure, it just seems like Java is a pretty easy language to do it in. But yeah, one time someone asked me to do, I can't remember, it was something like build an adder or something in c++ um so yeah thomas asks so this is sorry i should probably preface this so you know we're actually deviating a little bit from news i'm going to cover some some questions here so we'll be getting a lot of really interesting questions and uh you know we were making them kind of intro
所以 Thomas 确实写信问：我该如何为面试做准备？或者他具体问的是我们如何为面试做准备。我会说，基本上，看过我们和 Simple Programmer 的 John 那期节目的观众都知道，我以前经常做 Topcoder 和 HackerRank 之类的东西。所以我只是回到那里。我去 Topcoder，解决一堆练习题，这就差不多了。现在，有时我会被问到一些
topics but uh you know we could we could basically answer more questions if we kind of sprinkled them depending on sort of the the the scope of the question um so so thomas actually wrote in and he asked uh how do i prep for an interview and uh um or actually he specifically asked how do we prep for interviews. So I'll say I basically, you know, people who saw the episode that we did with Simple Programmer with John, you know, I used to do a lot of Topcoder and HackerRank and these things. And so I just go back there. So I go to Topcoder, you know, I solve a bunch of practice problems. And that's pretty much it. You know, now, like, there's some times where I get asked questions
非常机器学习相关的问题，所以我可能会复习一下那方面的内容。但这就是我所做的，我去 Topcoder 解决问题。Topcoder 的好处是，我想 HackerRank 也是，他们不仅给你代码，还给你答案，不仅是代码，
that are kind of very machine learning specific, and so I might just brush up on a couple of things there, but, yeah, that's really all I do is I just go on Topcoder and solve problems, and the nice thing about Topcoder, and I think HackerRank as well, is they give you the answer, not just the code, but they give you the answer, not just the code,
而是给你直观的解决这个问题的方法，就像每个问题的档案一样。所以如果你刚开始，或者遇到一些非常棘手的问题，不知道如何解决，或者如何快速解决，你可以随时“作弊”，看答案，也许能学到一些新的数据结构或算法，或者一些简化问题的方法。这就是我所做的。你呢，Patrick？嗯，哭？不。嗯，这就是你准备的方式。给自己打气。我站在镜子前告诉自己：“如果你只有一次机会……”不，我……好吧，就像 Jason 说的，我认为这是日常的。我不想讨论技术面试中必须写代码是否有意义，但这是我们行业目前的情况，很多公司要求你准备好回答编码问题。要知道这和你日常工作不同，你应该知道，如果你查一下或者注意一下……
but they give you intuitively how's the way to solve this problem, like a little dossier on each problem. And so if you're just starting out or you encounter some really tough problem and you don't really understand how can this be solved or how can it be solved quickly or something like that, you could always cheat, look at the answer and maybe learn some, some new data structure or some algorithm you didn't know, or some way to reduce the problem or something like that. Um, but yeah, that's, that's what I do. What about you, Patrick? Um, cry? No. Um, that's how you prepare. Psych myself. I stand in the mirror and tell myself if you had one shot one opportunity no i okay so sort of what jason said you know i think it's a day-to-day which okay i i don't i want to avoid getting into discussion about whether or not technical interviews where you have to write code makes sense but oh that's true saying saying that this
所以练习 Jason 说的那些为编程竞赛设计的题目是可以的。好吧，我不会去参加编程竞赛。是的，除了它们是为了让你在有限的时间内解决问题，并以一种非常受控的方式锻炼一些有趣的解谜推理能力、统计学能力，让别人能理解你的过程。
is what we deal with in the industry currently and that many companies you should be prepared to answer coding questions then know that it is different than what you do day to day they know that you should know that if you look it up or pay attention um and so practicing what jason's saying those style of questions that are made for programming contests are okay well i'm not going to compete in programming contests yeah except that they're built for you to solve in a constrained time period and exercise some interesting sort of puzzle solving reasoning aspects, aspects, statistics, in a very controlled manner where someone can understand your process.
这就是为什么它们是很好的练习，因为当你坐下来解决它时，它不是“使用 Raft 共识构建一个分布式数据存储”。没人能在这一小时内写出那个。我的意思是，如果你能，你可能已经有工作了。是的，所以你不能——我的意思是，你可以问那种问题，但你不能真的让人写出代码，太复杂了。所以编程竞赛或面试题非常适合让你思考字符串操作、数学运算、任意精度数字，这些你日常可能不会用到的东西。
And that's why they make a really good practice is because you know when you sit down to solve it, it isn't build a distributed data store using raft consensus for data contention resolution. No one's gonna write that in like an hour i mean if you do well like you probably would have a job um yeah and so you can't i mean you can ask about that kind of stuff but you can't really have a person write their code for that it's too complicated and so the programming contests or interview questions are great for getting your mind thinking about string manipulation, about math operations, about, you know, arbitrary precision, you know, numbers, these kinds of things that you may not use day to day.
这就是为什么它们是非常好的练习，因为你知道当你坐下来解决它时，它不是让你用Raft共识来构建一个分布式数据存储以解决数据争用。没有人能在一小时内写出那个，我的意思是如果你能做到，那你可能早就找到工作了。嗯，是的，所以你不能，我的意思是你可以问这类问题，但你不能真的让人现场写出那种代码，它太复杂了。所以编程竞赛或面试题非常适合让你思考字符串操作、数学运算，或者你知道的，任意精度数字，这些你日常工作中可能不会用到的东西。
And just, you know, a refresher for data structures and algorithms. But I also think that a lot of times it is good to practice the soft questions as well like why do you want this job why are you leaving your current job and research your company that you're applying for you know if someone asks you well why do you why do you want to come work at jason's amazing company then you know you say well jason's an amazing? Then, you know, you say, well, Jason's an amazing guy. And I, you know, whatever you're, you know, prepare for that because being caught flat footed,
还有，你知道，复习一下数据结构和算法。但我同时也认为，很多时候练习软技能问题也很有好处，比如你为什么想要这份工作，你为什么要离开目前的工作，以及研究你申请的公司。你知道，如果有人问你“你为什么想来杰森（Jason）那家很棒的公司工作”，然后你回答“因为杰森是个很棒的人”。那么，你知道，你要做好准备，因为如果被问得措手不及，
even if they sort of like, okay, whatever, not a big deal. He didn't answer that question or she didn't answer that question. Great. It throws you for a spin. And if you're, if you're sort of out of sorts, it's that much harder to bounce back. So prepare for the soft questions too and spend some amount of time thinking about how you want to present
即使他们觉得“好吧，无所谓，这没什么大不了的。他没回答那个问题，或者她没回答那个问题。”很好。这会让你感到慌乱。如果你处于那种不知所措的状态，想要恢复过来就难得多了。所以也要为软技能问题做好准备，花点时间思考一下你想如何展示
yourself so you know you know as much as i think at least here in california and silicon valley like there isn't an expectation to wear a suit you still want to look nice whatever you're going to wear even if you wear jeans and a t-shirt that like i interview people that are like that all the time that's fine i have no issue with that but you know it helps that much if you feel that you're dressed well i think it comes across like as silly as that sounds i think you know it's totally hold yourself better yeah that's a that's a great point um not everybody now i'm sure there's someone will say oh you know you know, I, you know, go in a bathrobe and I feel like I crush it every time. You know, you're probably right. Sure, that's true. But I think for a lot of people myself, I've noticed that if I take the time to prepare sort of what I'm going to wear, you know, if I, you know, make sure that I look presentable, then I sort of feel like I've done my due diligence.
你自己。所以，你知道，尽管我认为至少在加州和硅谷这里，并没有穿西装的要求，但你还是希望看起来体面。无论你穿什么，即使你穿牛仔裤和T恤——我面试的人经常那样穿，这没问题，我对此没意见——但你知道，如果你觉得你穿得很好，这会有很大帮助。我认为这会给人留下深刻印象。听起来可能很傻，但我认为这确实能让你表现得更好。是的，这是一个很好的观点。嗯，并不是每个人……我敢肯定有人会说：“哦，你知道，我穿着睡袍去面试，我觉得我每次都表现得非常出色。”你知道，你可能是对的。当然，那是真的。但我认为对很多人来说，包括我自己，我注意到如果我花时间准备我要穿的衣服，确保我看起来体面，那么我就觉得我已经尽到了应尽的责任。
And I think that comes across but yeah it makes sense I mean I think I think that you know the company like wants the company you're applying at sort of they want you to represent them and so you got to think like you know how you do the way you dress and the way you speak and your soft skills and all that is incredibly, incredibly important. And I think, oops, sorry, go ahead.
我认为这会给人留下印象。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我认为你申请的公司希望你代表他们，所以你必须考虑你的穿着、说话方式、软技能等等，这些都非常、非常重要。我想，噢，抱歉，你继续。
Oh, go ahead. I think preparing for the interview happens over, it sounds terrible. It happens every, over years. Like, yeah,
噢，你继续。我认为面试准备是……这听起来很糟糕。它是经过多年积累的。就像，是的，
that's true. You sort of the, it's not even 80, 20 sort of like the 99% of what will get you a job or not sort of takes a long time period, months, a year, years of sort of takes a long time period months a year years of sort of practicing being involved in this kind of thing you're not going to hack your way to you know one week of practice and you're going to ace the interview if you're really strategic and train yourself you know probably in a couple weeks a month a couple months you can probably do pretty
那是真的。这甚至不是80/20法则，可以说99%决定你能否得到工作的事情需要很长的时间，几个月、一年、几年，通过参与这类事情来练习。你不可能通过一周的练习就走捷径，然后就能在面试中表现出色。如果你非常有策略并训练自己，你知道，可能在几周、一个月、几个月内，你可能就能做得相当
well get yourself you know close the gap um but the bulk of it is stuff you really have to be ready for over longer periods of time. And so all the things we're discussing is to sort of take you the final distance is to differentiate you from the other people and to help just, you know, assure that you're that much more ready. Yeah, makes sense. So back to a news article i guess we should have changed the order of these uh this is an article i read a little while ago star stacker astrophotography with c++ 11 um so although this is yet another uh c++ based article uh just like the haskell one this is not much about c++ at all uh well the haskell one was about c++ but not about haskell this one's about astrophotography and not so much about c++
好，缩小差距。但大部分内容是你必须在更长的时间内做好准备的。所以我们讨论的所有事情都是为了让你走完最后一段路，让你与其他人区分开来，并帮助你确保你准备得更加充分。是的，有道理。那么回到新闻文章，我想我们应该改变一下顺序。这是一篇我前段时间读到的文章，《用C++ 11进行星空堆栈天文摄影》。虽然这又是另一篇基于C++的文章，就像那篇Haskell的文章一样，但这篇其实和C++没太大关系。嗯，Haskell那篇是关于C++的，但不是关于Haskell的；这一篇是关于天文摄影的，而不是关于C++的。
um where astrophotography is just taking pictures of stars uh and the i don't even remember if there was any c++ in this example doesn't look like it i think the person was not using open cv was the sort of trick here they were trying to not use open cv to do things where if you take a picture of the night sky your camera is really sensitive but if you take many pictures of the night sky you can sort of get rid of a lot of the noise that is inherent in taking a picture at night with low brightness. And although that sounds simple, that is really all astrophotography is sort of related, either gathering more light or sort of allowing you to what's called like integrate over longer periods of time,
嗯，天文摄影就是拍摄星星的照片。我甚至不记得这个例子里有没有C++代码，看起来好像没有。我认为这个人的诀窍在于没有使用OpenCV。他们试图不使用OpenCV来做这些事情。如果你拍摄夜空的照片，你的相机非常灵敏，但如果你拍摄多张夜空照片，你就可以消除很多在夜间低亮度下拍照时固有的噪点。虽然这听起来很简单，但这确实就是天文摄影的相关内容，要么是收集更多的光线，要么是允许你进行所谓的“长时间积分”，
like get more samples. But the problem is it turns out the earth is spinning shocker. It's also not flat. So the earth is a, is a spherical ish object and i yeah i know what i'm gonna get into that uh and we're spinning i don't know where the flat earthers have come from but it seems like that's like another thing again i want to believe it's just like a shtick like a meme like a joke yeah probably um anyways but the earth is spinning and so if you you know
也就是获取更多的样本。但问题是，地球是在自转的，真让人震惊。它也不是平的。所以地球是一个球体状的物体，我知道我要谈论这个了。我们正在旋转。我不知道地平论者是从哪里冒出来的，但这似乎又是另一回事。我还是想相信这只是一个噱头，一个梗，一个笑话。是的，可能吧。嗯，无论如何，地球是在自转的，所以如果你
hold the camera on a tripod pointed in a direction for very long past you know sort of i think like 10 or 15 seconds the distance the star will move will show up across you know a couple pixels and you'll get what's called blur um so the the star will be blurred on not in a sort of gauzing way but in a line along the direction. And so if you leave a camera open for like half an hour, you'll start to get star trails, like these little concentric circles of the stars moving. Well, I guess the stars are fixed and the Earth is spinning.
把相机放在三脚架上，朝一个方向对准很长时间，超过10或15秒，星星移动的距离就会在几个像素上显示出来，你会得到所谓的“模糊”。所以星星会变得模糊，不是那种高斯模糊，而是沿着方向的一条线。所以如果你把相机打开半小时，你就会开始得到星轨，就像星星移动形成的同心圆。好吧，我想星星是固定的，而地球在自转。
And so as you try to take longer and longer samples of the night sky, you need to sort of track where the stars are so that you can align all the pictures on top of each other and that's what this goes over uh and i knew a lot of this stuff but it was i thought this article did a really good job of sort of a clear explanation from i guess kind of first principles um and what they end up with other there's already software that does this so you don't need to do this on your own um and there's you know more advanced techniques than what's presented here but i thought this was a really good presentation of like if you wanted to approach this really complicated subject on your own
所以当你试图对夜空进行越来越长的采样时，你需要跟踪星星的位置，以便将所有照片对齐叠加在一起，这就是这篇文章所涉及的内容。我以前知道很多这些东西，但我认为这篇文章做得很好，从第一性原理出发进行了清晰的解释。他们最终得到的结果是，已经有软件可以做到这一点，所以你不需要自己动手。而且还有比这里介绍的更先进的技术，但我认为这是一个非常好的展示，如果你想自己处理这个非常复杂的主题，
without you know just using open cv for a lot of this stuff here's the principles of it yeah very cool so do they just register the images on top of each other or do they literally calculate, you know, the Earth's rotation and all of that? So I don't actually know of anyone. They might calculate the Earth's rotation. In this one, they more do like figuring out constellations of stars and figuring out how the constellations move between frames. Got it. But I don't think they try to sort of predict where the next one will be. Okay.
而不只是在很多地方使用OpenCV，这里就是其中的原理。是的，非常酷。所以他们只是把图像注册叠加在一起，还是他们真的计算了地球的自转和所有这些？我其实不知道有谁这样做。他们可能会计算地球的自转。在这篇文章中，他们更多的是找出星座，并计算星座在帧之间是如何移动的。明白了。但我不认为他们试图预测下一个位置会在哪里。好的。
Makes sense. But I, you should write that, Jason. All right. That's what I'll do with all the extra time we have. I mean, I guess you probably don't start off with a very fine measurement of where you're pointing. So it probably makes it pretty hard. Yeah.
有道理。但你应该写那个，杰森。好的。这就是我利用我们所有额外时间要做的事情。我的意思是，我想你可能一开始并没有对你的指向位置进行非常精确的测量。所以这可能让它变得相当困难。是的。
So you'd have to also sort of figure out the field of view and where you're pointing, and you'd have to build a model of that up you have to do basically slam slam in space space slam space jam space space slam with michael jordan and bugs bunny for reasons that's right uh so now book of the show um so i read i read a couple of kind of interesting books i wouldn't really recommend them um so i'm not really going to i'm actually going to recommend a classic that you know i've read several times which which i which i love called uh the name is 1984 i'm sure everyone's heard of it it's by george orwell um he also wrote our watership down i believe is george orwell um but he's written a bunch of books about society and uh and yeah 1984 is is i would say almost certainly his most uh famous book and uh yeah without kind of spoiling too much basically uh um it just covers sort of like it's it's a
所以你还得弄清楚视场和你的指向位置，你必须建立一个模型。你基本上必须在太空中做SLAM（即时定位与地图构建）。太空SLAM，太空大灌篮，迈克尔·乔丹和兔八哥，原因就是这样。好的，现在是本期节目的推荐书目。我读了几本挺有意思的书，但我不太推荐它们。所以我不会推荐那些，我实际上要推荐一本我读过好几次的经典名著，我非常喜欢，书名是《1984》。我相信每个人都听说过，作者是乔治·奥威尔。他还写了《水底沉舟》（Watership Down），我相信是乔治·奥威尔写的。但他写了很多关于社会的书。是的，《1984》我敢肯定几乎是他最著名的书。是的，在不剧透太多的情况下，基本上它涵盖了……它是一本
fiction book about this sort of totalitarian regime and uh it's where the term kind of big brother came from and basically the idea is that uh in this book the government uh like literally just has censors everywhere and they're monitoring everything and they've also sort of trained the the people to uh they've brainwashed you know the citizens um and i'm trying not to spoil too much here but basically uh um you know they've brainwashed them to sort of uh you know tell if another person is committing a crime and stuff like that um and then they have something called thought crime where people are just thinking about committing a crime and go to jail um and so 1984 is the basis for you know like the paranoia book series and in a bunch of other
关于这种极权主义政权的虚构小说，这就是“老大哥”（Big Brother）这个词的由来。基本上，书中的政府到处都有审查员，他们监控一切，而且他们还训练人们……他们洗脑了公民。我尽量不剧透太多，但基本上，他们洗脑了他们，让他们去举报另一个人是否在犯罪之类的。然后他们有一种叫“思想罪”的东西，人们仅仅因为考虑犯罪就会进监狱。所以《1984》是偏执狂系列书籍以及其他许多
uh you know uh just all sorts of different uh you know books and films and memes and commentary and stuff like that you'll hear 1984 referenced very often and so it's a great book um uh it's super fun to read and uh yeah it's my book of the show oh also you could get it for free it's it's a classic um it has no i don't know uh uh like copyright or anything like that um and so there's a link in the show notes to the actual book you don't have to pay for it i don't think you meant watership down i think it's animal farm oh that's what it is yeah who wrote watership i have no idea all right so the my book of this show is Words of Radiance, which is part of the Stormlight Archive series by Brandon Sanderson.
书籍、电影、梗和评论的基础。你会经常听到人们提到《1984》，所以这是一本很棒的书。读起来超级有趣。是的，这是我本期的推荐书目。噢，你也可以免费获得它，这是一本经典名著，它没有任何版权之类的。所以节目笔记里有一个链接指向这本书，你不需要为此付费。我不认为你指的是《水底沉舟》，我认为是《动物庄园》。噢，是那个。是的，谁写的《水底沉舟》？我不知道。好的，那么我本期的推荐书目是《光辉真言》（Words of Radiance），这是布兰登·桑德森（Brandon Sanderson）的《飓光志》（Stormlight Archive）系列的一部分。
And I recommended, this is the second book, and I recommended the first one previously, I'm quite sure, The Way of Kings. And so I recently finished the second book. And this is, I guess, on schedule for once because the third book is coming out November 14th. So, um, nice.
我推荐过，这是第二本书，我之前推荐过第一本，我很确定，叫《王者之路》（The Way of Kings）。所以我最近读完了第二本书。我想这次进度还算准时，因为第三本书将在11月14日出版。所以，不错。
If you, now there's a problem though, which is, uh, so I listened to these books on audio because I, they're really long. Um, but the first book was 45 and a half hours.
现在有个问题，就是我听的是这些书的有声书，因为它们太长了。第一本书是45个半小时。
The second book is, it was 48 hours. Um, and so the good news is if by the time you listen to this you could in theory make it through all the books just in time for the third book to come out but the bad news is that's like or the good news i guess depending is i mean that's like almost 100 hours of uh audio i don't even know how many pages that would be a lot of pages, but 100 hours between now and November 14. If you want to get them all done in time for the release party for the third
第二本书是48小时。好消息是，如果你在听这期节目的时候，理论上你可以在第三本书出版前刚好读完所有书。但坏消息是，或者说好消息取决于你怎么看，这大约有100小时的音频。我甚至不知道那会有多少页，会有很多页。但在现在到11月14日之间有100小时，如果你想在第三本书的发布派对前全部读完的话。
night in the series. Yeah, marathon audio book. I don't know if that's been done before. So no, okay, I have to say at least something about the book. so i recommend a lot of brandon sanderson books i guess i i don't know i it is what it is i i enjoy his writing style uh and i i don't think i'm the only one um but basically this continues where the first book left off and that means i can't say anything about it because basically anything i say about the second book is going to be a spoiler for the first book so if you liked the first book this one is also really good if you didn't like the first book you know i never know what to do if i read the first book of a trilogy or a series and i don't like it it's like well i could go on and it's like well what because if i read the second book i'm gonna quit two-thirds of the way through um so i guess start it and plan to make
系列中的那一晚。是的，马拉松式有声书。我不知道以前有没有人这样做过。好吧，我至少得说点关于这本书的内容。我推荐了很多布兰登·桑德森的书，我不知道，事实就是这样。我喜欢他的写作风格，我不认为我是唯一一个。但基本上，这本书延续了第一本书的结尾，这意味着我什么都不能说，因为我说的任何关于第二本书的内容都会剧透第一本书。所以如果你喜欢第一本书，这一本也很好。如果你不喜欢第一本书，我从来不知道该怎么办。如果我读了一个三部曲或系列的第一本书，我不喜欢它，我会想“我还要继续吗？”因为如果我读了第二本书，我会在读到三分之二时放弃。所以我想，开始读吧，并计划把它读完，尽管这是一个很大的承诺。到最后，总时长可能会接近150小时。但《光辉真言》值得推荐，如果你读完了第一本的话。如果你还没读过第一本，
it all the way through although that's a big commitment it'll probably I guess by the time it's all said and done be close to 150 hours anyways but the Words of Radiance is an endorsement if you finish the first book and if you haven't read the first
去读吧，它真的很棒。这是奇幻小说，我喜欢它。《王者之路》是第一本，《光辉真言》是第二本。我想第三本会叫《誓约之剑》（Oathbringer），我不能说为什么这个名字有意义，但我不能说。好的，不剧透。不剧透。非常酷。所以你可以在Audible上读所有这些书。如果你还没有Audible账户，你可以去我们的节目笔记，我们有一个链接，是audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。如果你访问那个网址，你可以注册并获得一本免费书，
book go read it it's really good it's fantasy and I like it and The way of Kings book one words of radiance book two. And the third one I think is going to be called oath bringer, which I can't say why that means something, but I can't say why. Okay, no spoilers. No spoilers. Very cool. So you can read all those books on audible. And if you don't yet have an audible account you can actually uh go to our show notes we have a link um it's audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown if you go to that that url you can actually sign up and get a free book uh with your subscription
通过点击那个链接，这也能帮助我们维持节目的运行。对于已经有Audible或者想以其他方式支持我们的人，我们有Patreon。快到圣诞节了，所以圣诞节时，我们会把从节目中获得的额外资金拿出来，买一些T恤送给随机的人。所以，你可以完全……那个词怎么说来着？你可以通过在这个月成为订阅者来“狙击”Patreon。不。我想我们会想出一个比那更公平的方法。
by clicking on that link and also that uh helps us keep the show up and running so uh we also for people already have audible or want to support us in another way we have patreon um it's getting pretty close to christmas so at christmas we take you know whatever extra money we have from the show um and we spend it on t-shirts that we give to random people. So, you know, we don't, you could totally, what's the word? You could totally snipe the Patreon. No. By becoming a subscriber this month. I think we're going to come up with, I think we're going to have a more fair way than that.
好的，也许我们会做一些轮盘抽样之类的。但如果你是Patreon订阅者，作为订阅的一部分，我们可以访问电子邮件地址列表，我们不会与任何人分享，我们只用它来发放免费T恤。所以，当接近圣诞节时，在11月或12月初，我们会开始给一些T恤获奖者发邮件。所以，来看看我们，网址是patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。我想说声谢谢。我的意思是，
Okay, maybe we'll do some roulette wheel sampling or something. But yeah, if you're a Patreon subscriber um you know as part of of subscribing we get access to the list of email addresses which we don't share with anybody uh we only use it for giving out free t-shirts and so uh when it gets close to christmas sometime in november early december we'll uh we'll start emailing some some winners of t-shirts so uh check us out uh it's patreon.com slash programming throw down. And I want to say thank you. I mean,
我知道有不少人。我前几天看了页面，我们现在有相当多的人在支持。我也知道每个月，
I know a fair number of people. I looked on the page on the other day. I, we've got a, a quite a few people now shipping. And I know also there's, you know, every month,
都有一些人参加Audible试用。所以我很受鼓舞，我觉得人们能从中受益真是太好了。而且，
a number of people who do the audible trial thing. And so I was encouraging, like, I guess, I mean, I don't, it's nice to see that people hopefully are benefiting from this. And,
我也看了我们iTunes上的评论数量。我们已经有一段时间没推过这个了，也没怎么谈论过。我不知道我们是否真的推过，但已经好几年了。
you know, also I looked at their day, the number of reviews we're getting on iTunes. We haven't really pushed that in a while or talked about it. I don't know if we've ever really pushed it, but, um, it's been years.
是的。我的意思是，我想说，而且我认为是你，当你去iTunes时，你只能看到你所在国家的评论，
Yes. Yeah. I mean, I think I, I want to say, and I think it's you, when you go to iTunes, you see only for your country,
我相信是这样。噢，我不知道。我想那是真的。噢，我不知道。我想那是真的。而且我认为我们现在在iTunes上有超过300条评论。哇。太棒了。
I believe is true. Um, Oh, I didn't know that. I think that's true. Oh, I didn't know that. I think that's true. And I think we have over 300 reviews now on iTunes. Wow. That's amazing.
所以感谢所有这样做的人。如果你还没做，而且不打算给我们评分，就像那个应用一样。你不喜欢我们吗？如果你不喜欢我们，就别去评分。但如果你真的很喜欢，如果你讨厌我们，
So thanks to all those people who did it. And if you haven't done it and you're not going to rate us, it's like the app thing. Do you not like us? If you don't like us, don't go rate us. But if you really like it, if you hate us,
给我们发邮件。如果你喜欢我们，给我们评分，给我们发邮件。如果你喜欢我们，给我们评分，然后给我们发邮件。其实，是的，如果你讨厌我们，给我们发邮件到definitelynotouremail@gmail.com。没错，我们绝对不会回复……我们绝对会回复。是的，没错，最终会回复的。噢，天哪。酷，所以非常感谢所有的支持，也感谢所有的邮件。最近的很多节目要么是来自我们采访过的听众，要么是来自听众建议的节目主题。所以谢谢你们。是的，我们确实尽量回复所有的邮件。但我得找个借口，我觉得很抱歉。
send us an email. If you like us, rate us and us send us an email if you like us rate us and then send us an email actually yeah if you hate us send us an email at definitely not our email at gmail.com that's right and we definitely won't we'll reply we definitely will reply yeah that's right eventually oh man um cool so yeah thank you so so much for all the support and for all the emails, too. A lot of the shows recently have been either people that we were connected with from listeners that we've interviewed or show topics that have also come from listeners. So thank you for that. Yeah, and we do try to get back to all of the emails. But I will say as an excuse, I guess I feel bad about it.
有时邮件是在非常忙的时候进来的，所以并不总是能及时回复。所以如果你的邮件没有得到快速回复，提前道歉。是的，我也是。我实际上发现了一堆我在六个月前度假时标记的邮件。我一直没处理。有些人最近收到了六个月前邮件的回复。
Sometimes emails come in during a really busy time, and so they don't always get responded to expediently. So apologize in advance if your emails don't get speedy responses. Yeah, same here. I actually found just a bunch of email that I flagged while I was on vacation about six months ago. I never got to. Some people recently got an email from a reply from a six-month-old email.
所以我为此道歉。但我们确实看了所有的邮件。我们尽量回复尽可能多的邮件。本期工具。好的。我们整场节目都在卖关子。我准备好了。没错。
So I apologize for that. But yeah, we definitely look at all of them. And we try to reply to as many as possible. Tool of the show. All right. So we've been teased all show. I'm ready for this. That's right.
我的本期工具是Wi-Fi InfoView。这只是我碰巧找到的。这是我在谷歌上找到的第一个。可能还有其他的。但它基本上就是弹出一个菜单，显示你能看到的所有Wi-Fi接入点，它们在哪个频道，你对它们的信号强度是多少，以及分贝的噪声水平是多少。这就是RSSI，它是某种噪声的对数。所以基本上，你可以看看这个，然后采取策略。例如，有一次我遇到这个问题，我在玩电子游戏，它开始有点卡顿。
My tool of the show is Wi-Fi InfoView. So this is just one I happened to. It's just the first thing I found on Google. There's probably others. But basically what it does is it just pulls up this menu with all the Wi-Fi access points you can see, what channel they're on, what your signal strength is to all of them, and what the level of noise and decibels is. It's the RSSI, which is some kind of like log, logarithm of the noise. And so basically, you can look at this and then kind of be strategic. So for example, one time I had this issue where I was playing this video game, and it started kind of stuttering.
这大约是一周前的事。我想，这有点奇怪，因为我们有这个我引以为傲的Wi-Fi设置，它突然就开始出故障了。所以我拔掉了调制解调器，做了所有这些，似乎什么都没修好。所以我用了这个工具，看起来不错。最终发生的事情是，我因为之前为了修复某些东西切换到了扩展器，结果不小心一直连接在扩展器上，我从来没切回来。
This was like a week or so ago. I thought, that's kind of strange because, you know, we have this Wi-Fi setup that I'm pretty proud of, and it's just all of a sudden kind of glitching out. And so I unplugged my modem and did all that, and nothing seemed to fix it. So I went on this tool, and it looked good. What ended up happening is I ended up being connected to the extender by accident because I switched over to the extender to kind of fix something and I never switched back.
但有了这个工具，我能够看到我对扩展器的信号质量真的很低，这很合理，因为我用的是房子另一头的电脑。但我对主路由器的信号质量仍然很好。此外，你还会有频道冲突。所以如果你和你的邻居都在同一个频道上有路由器，你们会互相干扰。所以你可以用这个工具检测到这一点。所以有了这个工具，它可能会说：“嘿，你的信号强度是80%，而且在你的公寓大楼里有三个人在同一个频道上。”所以你就可以进入你的路由器更改频道。你甚至可以玩其他东西，比如如果你
But with this tool, I was able to see, you know, my signal quality to the extender is really low, which makes sense because I was using a computer that's on the other side of the house. But my signal quality to, you know, the main router was still really good and everything. Also, you know, you can have channel collisions. So if you and your next door neighbor both have a router on the same channel, you'll sort of interfere with each other. And so you can actually detect that with this tool. So with this tool, it might say, hey, you know, your signal strength is, you know, 80%. And there's three other people with the same channel in your apartment complex. And so then you could just go in your router and change a channel. You can actually play with other things too like if you uh take the
如果你有一个USB天线，USB Wi-Fi天线，你实际上可以看到，噢，如果我把它贴在墙上，我的信号强度就会上升。如果我把天线指向错误的方向，它就会下降。所以，是的，这个工具让正在发生的事情变得非常透明。原因在于，因为还有几件事，当我们变得极客一点时，我们已经谈论过网络了。在2.4GHz频段，并非所有频道都是平等的。所以大多数在你的路由器上列出的频道，如果你费心去配置它，都会与其他频道重叠。所以实际上只有，我想，五个？是的，没错。
if you have you know a usb um uh you know antenna usb uh uh wi-fi antenna you can actually see oh if i put it up like if i tape it to the wall my signal strength goes up you know if i if i you know point the antenna in the wrong direction it goes goes down. And so, yeah, the tool just makes it very transparent what's going on. And the reason, because there's a couple of things too, while we get nerdy, and we've already talked about networking a little. In 2.4 gigahertz, not all channels are created equal. So most of the channels that are listed on your router, if you bother to go in and configure it, overlap with other channels. So there's actually only, I think, like five? Yeah, that's right.
五个不重叠的频道。所有其他的都互相重叠。所以它会让你选择它们，但你会遇到两倍的冲突。是的，这不理想。当发生冲突时，会发生什么？我的意思是，我想如果你上过网络课程，或者如果你学过网络或任何射频知识，你就会学到这个。
Five channels that don't overlap. All the others overlap with each other. So it'll let you pick them, but you'll have twice as many collisions. Yeah, it's not ideal. And what happens when you collide is that, I mean, I guess this is what you'll learn about if you ever take like networking or if you've taken networking or any just rf stuff it's like what you
你听说过CSMA/CA，载波侦听多路访问/冲突避免，这基本上是无线电在两个人同时在同一频率发送时侦测到额外的能量。你会说，噢，有两个人正在说话，然后你进入冲突避免，某种指数退避，你的邻居也是，那么你进入这种指数退避的机会就越大，这会减慢一切速度。这就是为什么你要避免在同一个频道上的原因。是的，有道理。所以，是的，并非所有频道都是平等的。
hear a csma ca or whatever clarior sends multiple access uh collision avoidance which is basically the radio senses when two people are sending on the same frequency at the same time, you basically have extra energy. And you go, oh, two people are talking, and you enter into collision avoidance, sort of exponential backoff and your neighbor, then the more chance that you have to enter into this exponential backoff, which slows everything down. So that's why you want to avoid being on the same channel. Yeah, that makes sense. So yeah, not all channels are created equal.
5GHz更好。它有更多的频道。所以带宽，频道的数量更多，因为有更多的带宽可以利用。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，如果你在5GHz上，还要提一下，尽量避免像148、149这样非常高的频道，因为你实际上会开始干扰手机波长。要么那样，要么调大路由器的功率。是的，没错，你邻居里就没人能打电话了。
Five gigahertz is better. It has a lot more channels. So the bandwidth, the number of channels is bigger because there's more bandwidth to play with yeah exactly i mean the other thing just to mention real quick if you are on five gigahertz is uh try to avoid the really high channels like 148 149 because you'll actually start to interfere with uh the cell phone wavelength so either that or crank up the power on your router yeah that's right no one in your neighborhood would be able to make calls.
但是的，在欧洲情况不同。但在美国，我们的手机频段会干扰那个。所以选择一个低频道，比如40或48之类的。但你可以使用Wi-Fi InfoView看到所有这些。你可以选择像148这样的频道，你会看到你的信号强度开始下降。我的本期工具是由……噢，上周我们谈论了音乐制作工具，小工具。噢，Gadget是其中一个工具的名字。我想那是你的本期工具。
But yeah, it's different in Europe. But in the U.S., our cell bands can interfere with that. So pick a low channel like 40 or 48 or something like that. But you could actually see all of this using Wi-Fi InfoView. You could pick a channel like 148 and you'll see your signal strength will start to go down uh my tool of the show was sent in by oh last week we or last week last episode we talked about two or we talked about uh music making things gadgets uh oh gadget is the name of one of the tools. I think was your tool of the show.
那是什么？Korg。是的，Gadget。我想是Korg。Gadget是名字。我们谈论了人们。嘿，大家给我们发些音乐吧。我们可以换掉我们的片头。我们确实有两个人发来了音乐。所以我们可能会开始，你知道，至少放一些音乐作为片尾，直到我们……我们这个片头已经用了很长时间了。我想我已经对它产生了一些怀旧之情。所以我们会看看是否要换掉片头。但我们肯定会有一些片尾曲。所以提前感谢那两个人。其中一个人实际上发送了一个工具的建议，我以前见过，但我从没玩过。所以我采纳他们的建议，如果不好用我们可以怪他们，那就是SunVox。所以SunVox
What was that? Korg. Yeah. Gadget. I think it's Korg. Gadget was the name. And we talked about people. Hey, people send us some music. We can change our intro. And we actually had two people send in some music. So we'll probably start, you know, putting some music at least as outros until we, you know, we've had this same intro for a really long time. I guess I've become somewhat nostalgic for it. So we'll see about if we'll switch over the intro. But definitely we're going to have some outro tunes. And so thanks to those two people in advance. And one of them actually sent a tip for a tool, which I had seen before, but I've never played with. So I'm going on their recommendation so we can blame them if it's bad and that is Sun Vox so Sun Vox
是一个模块化音序器，可以在多种平台上运行。列表上写着Windows、macOS、Linux、Windows CE（如果你有那些旧PDA的话）、iOS、Android。它有一个超级老派的界面，但我认为它看起来很酷。而且有各种各样的演示，人们制作的音乐比我能做的要好得多。所以，去看看吧，SunVox。如果你喜欢摆弄
is a modular sequencer that runs on like a plethora of platforms so the list says Windows Mac OS Linux Windows te if you have one of those old PDAs iOS Android and it is has a super old school looking interface, but I think it looks kind of cool. And there's all sorts of demos of people making music that's way better than I could ever make. And so, you know, check it out, Sunvox. If you like fiddling around
并制作很棒的音乐和声音，或者如果你像我一样，喜欢制作出连亲妈都听不下去的最糟糕的声音，或者如果你像我一样，音乐天赋太差，以至于你做出了可怕的东西，却觉得它听起来不错。我想我显然很糟糕，我意识到我不可能做出任何好的东西，即使我做出了好的东西，因为它是出自我的手，我也会假设它不好。这就是我做的。是的，我的意思是，听起来就像……我心想“噢，这听起来像我在收音机里听到的电子舞曲”，但我知道它听起来那样只是因为我没有天赋。
and making awesome music and sounds, or if you're like me and you like making the worst possible sounding thing that not even a mother could love or if you're like me and you uh have so little musical talent that you make something terrible and you think it sounds good i guess i'm obviously bad that i realize i can't have made anything good even if i made something good because it came from me i would just assume it wasn't that's what i do yeah i mean it's like it sounds like it's i'm like oh it sounds like a techno song i would hear on the radio but i know that it only sounds that way to me because i have no talent
那是迈克尔推荐的SunVox。噢，是的，抱歉，我试图找到它，但我太慢了。谢谢你，杰森。是的，谢谢迈克尔。所以，谢谢迈克尔。那么，进入办公空间。嗯，这也是一个请求，我不记得是谁提的了，我稍后再查。但有人写信说，你们能谈谈你们的办公空间是什么样的吗？你们的桌子是什么样的？太棒了。你知道，所有这些。是的，没错，太棒了。在月球上，地下。是的，在月球上的地堡里。那太棒了。在地堡里写代码，那会像一场很棒的黑客马拉松，像一个黑客空间。好的，那么，但不幸的是，我们并不是都有地堡。我们大多数人基本上在三种，或者说四种不同的环境中工作。你要么在隔间里工作，
that was michael who recommended sunbox oh yeah sorry i was trying to find it but i was too slow thank you jason yeah thank you michael so yeah thanks michael so on to office spaces so um this is also a request i don't remember who off the top of my head i can i'll look it up later on but uh um yeah there's someone wrote in and said you know can you guys talk about sort of different what your office space is like your desk is like awesome you know all of that yeah that's right it's amazing it's on the moon underground yeah yeah in a bunker on the moon that would be awesome coding in a bunker that'd be like a great hackathon like a hacker space all right um so so yeah so but unfortunately we don't all have bunkers uh most of us work in basically three or i guess let's say four different environments you either work in cubicles
那可能是最常见的，尽管办公空间……是的，完全正确。所以你有这些……它们是用什么做的？聚酯纤维织物，某种刨花板之类的，或者我想还有《黑客帝国》里的矩阵，尼奥
that's probably the most common although office space yeah exactly so you have these like what are they made of like fabric like polyester fabric some particle board or something or I guess also the matrix right Neo
是……是的，没错。所以，你知道，这些墙没有一直延伸到天花板，所以每个人都有一定的隐私。你不能把头探过隔间墙之类的。你会在办公室里工作，所以有些公司每个人都有自己的办公室，你有一个迷宫般的走廊连接着所有办公室。有时一个办公室里也会坐四、五、六个人。是的，那是真的。
was yeah that's right yeah so you know it's these like walls that don't go all the way to the ceiling and so everyone kind of has some amount of privacy um you can't peek your head over the cubicle wall and all of that um you'll work in an office so there's some companies where each person you know has their own office and you have this sort of labyrinth uh of hallways connecting all the and sometimes you can have as many as four, five, six people sit in a single office as well. Yeah, that's true.
是的，这并不一定意味着一个人一个办公室。但这意味着你可以关上门。所以除了办公室里的人，你是与世隔绝的。是的。还有一种“牛栏”（bullpen），如果你有足够大的房间，可以容纳多达一千人，都在一个巨大的房间里。这和隔间的区别在于你没有墙。所以你只是桌子挨着桌子。但在这种非常大的环境中，通常在牛栏环境中，会有一些预留的空间，有沙发之类的。
Yeah, it doesn't necessarily mean one person per office. But, you know, it does mean you can close the door. And so other than the people in the office, you're insulated. Yeah. There's also a bullpen where you can have up to a thousand people if you have a big enough room that are there's all in one gigantic room. And the difference between this and cubicles is you don't have the walls. So you'll be just desk to desk to desk. But in this very large environment, typically in a bullpen environment, there'll be sort of spaces reserved, which have, you know, couches and stuff like that.
这样如果你想要更舒适，或者想伸展一下腿，或者想和某人交谈，在一个更私密的环境中，你可以这样做。但大多数人并不称它们为牛栏。大多数人称之为开放式办公室。是的，没错。就像大多数人说“噢，开放式办公室”，那实际上只是意味着每个人都挤在一个大房间里。是的，人们有点误用了那个词。最后一种基本上是你的家。很多人远程办公。但为什么你不告诉……抱歉，你继续。你真的觉得远程办公那么普遍吗？谈论这一节的内容将有点偏向杰森和
Just so that if you want to, you know, something more comfortable or you want to stretch your legs or you want to talk to somebody, you know, kind of a more private setting, you can do that. But most people don't call them bullpens. Most people call this open office. Yeah, right. Like that's what most people they say, oh, open office office that really just means everyone crammed in a big room together yeah yeah people kind of misuse that the last one is basically your house a lot of people telecommute um but yeah why don't you tell sorry go ahead do you really find telecommuting that common um speaking and all of this section is going to be sort of skewed to the limited views of jason and
我的有限观点，因为没有在各种各样的地方工作过，而且主要是在硅谷工作。是的，我的意思是，我现在工作的地方，每个人周三都远程办公。好的，所以这有点像……我的意思是，不是每个人，当然不是每个人，但很多人。但总的来说，这并不是那么普遍。我认为有一种想法是，如果你身体在那里，你就能有一种更强的协作感之类的。所以，是的。所以其中一件事是，这在工作中谈论开放式办公室时提到了，我读了一些东西，我意识到的一件事是，噢，有趣。
i as far as like having not worked at a ton of variety of different places and mostly working in silicon valley yeah i mean um i mean where i work now everyone telecommutes on wednesdays okay um so that's kind of like a i mean not everyone not everyone, of course, but, but a lot of people. But yeah, in general, it's, it's not really that common. I think there's this idea that, you know, if you're there physically, you're able to sort of have a heightened sense of, you know, collaboration and things like that. So, yeah. So one of the things is like, you know, this came up at work talking about open offices and I did a little bit of reading and one of the things I realized is, Oh, interesting.
我从来没去过那样的地方，但开放式办公室在真正意义上的“开放”下，可能意味着没有固定座位。就像你带一台笔记本电脑，有一堆野餐桌或学校食堂风格的桌子之类的。无论你目前和哪个团队一起工作，你就坐在他们旁边。人们只是四处走动，如果一个小组很吵，你就起来换个地方，无论如何，你只是四处流动，坐在任何你想坐的地方。我从来没在那种办公室里待过。它
I've never been at a place like this, but open office could, could really mean in the, in the, in a very true sense of open, no assigned seats. Like you bring a laptop and there's a bunch of, you know, picnic tables or sort of school cafeteria style tables or whatever it might be. And whatever team you're sort of working with currently, you just sit next to them. And people just sort of mingle around, you get up and move if a group is noisy, whatever, you just sort of flow around and sit wherever you want. I've never been in an office like that. It
听起来很酷。听起来有点疯狂。但你知道，我想有些人适合这种方式，特别是如果你的团队非常活跃，而且增长很快，我可以想象这在什么地方会有用。但对于大多数公司来说，以这种方式闻名的公司之一是Valve。所以Valve有一个开放式办公室，基本上，他们有一个人是粒子物理专家，我的意思是，游戏内粒子物理。所以，如果一个团队说：“噢，我的火球粒子看起来不像我想要的样子”，那么他就会和那个团队坐在一起，
sounds kind of cool. Sounds kind of crazy. But you know, I guess some people this works for them, especially I guess, if your teams are really dynamic, and you're growing a lot like i could imagine where this would be useful but for most the team that the company that's famous for this or one of them is valve so valve has an open office and basically you know they have one guy who's like a particle physics expert like i mean in-game particle physics and And so, you know, he just, you know, if a team says, oh, you know, my fireball particle, like, isn't looking the way I want it to look, then he'll sit with that team,
然后他会和另一个团队坐在一起。所以他们，我想Valve的设置方式是他们有所有这些专家，所以这种设置有利于他们能够四处走动。所以他们想，为什么不让每个人都四处走动呢？我不知道这一点。但我认为在大多数地方，大多数人都有固定座位，你可以带一张家人的照片，或者把你的桌子布置成你想要的样子。而且我
and then he'll sit with some other team. And so they, I guess the way Valve is set up is they have all these specialists, and so it's kind of conducive to that sort of setup that they could be able to move around. And so they figured, why not just have everyone move around? I didn't know that. But I think think in most places most people have assigned seats um and you can you know bring in a picture of your family or you know get your desk just the way you want it um and i
认为那是目前为止最常见的。对我来说，我在硅谷的经历是，你经常搬动，你的团队可能每六个月或更久就会搬一次。所以你在四处走动，你可能在同一栋楼里搬，你的空间可能只是被重新配置了，你可能搬到另一栋楼。但是的，你搬得很频繁。我从来没完全弄明白为什么。但团队规模增长和缩小的速度太快了，以至于这个团队需要更多空间。为了给他们更多空间，你必须搬动另一个团队。噢，我明白了。是的，有道理。
think that's sort of the most common um by far and for me my experience out here in silicon valley has been you move a lot you know your team moves probably you know every six months or more um and so you're moving around you might move within the same building your spaces just might get reconfigured you might move to a different building um but yeah you move pretty often, I've never quite figured out why. But team sizes just grow and shrink so fast that like this team needs more space. In order to give them more space, you have to move a different team. Oh, I see. Yeah, that makes sense.
是的。某种类似碎片整理的东西。是的。然后我想。是的。噢，你继续。是的。而且我认为，办公室的另一个共同点是有一些区域可以进行团队会议或小组会议，会议室。它们通常有白板，可以容纳6到20人。有时有更大的，但这很典型。你会让几个这样的会议室散布在你的工作空间周围。
Yeah. Some kind of like defragging type thing. Yeah. And then I think. Yeah. Oh, go ahead. Yeah. And I think, you know, the other common thing to offices is having some area where you can have team meetings or group meetings, conference rooms. They don't, you know, they typically have whiteboards and, you know, sort of like six to 20 people. And sometimes there's bigger ones, but that's pretty typical. And you'd have several of those kind of scattered around your workspace.
所以想想电视节目《办公室》（The Office），虽然它已经停播了。每个人，或者说大多数团队成员都坐在一个大的公共区域，所有的销售人员。然后迈克尔·斯科特会把他们叫进会议室。是的，这实际上很典型。是的，这很正常。我的意思是，很多会议室都会有书写的地方。所以他们可能有一面可以书写的墙，或者他们会有很多黑板或白板之类的东西。
So think about, you know, The Office on TV, the TV show The Office, which no longer runs, you know. Everyone kind of, well, most of the group sort of sat in a big common area, all of the, I guess, salespeople. And then they, Michael Scott would call them into the conference room. And yeah, that's actually pretty typical. Yep, that's pretty normal. I mean, a lot of conference rooms will have some way to write. So they might have like a wall that's writable or they'll have a bunch of blackboards or whiteboards or something like that.
所以想想看，比如电视节目《办公室》，虽然它已经停播了。每个人，或者说大部分团队成员都坐在一个大的公共区域，所有的销售人员都是这样。然后迈克尔·斯科特会把他们叫进会议室。是的，这其实很典型。没错，这很正常。我的意思是，很多会议室都会有书写工具。所以他们可能有一面可以书写的墙，或者有一堆黑板、白板之类的东西。
And the other thing is conference rooms are typically uh have some way of reserving them so the calendar system or whatever where you sort of book a conference room for a time period and that's where you hold your meetings yep so yeah totally um yeah so so that's basically how the most almost every office is set up um going to like your desk um i personally have always had standing desks. So Patrick and I used to work together a long time ago. And where we worked, we had to deal with kind of a lot of robotics and machinery. And so I was always standing. The desks were always standing there.
还有一点是，会议室通常都有预订方式，比如日历系统之类的，你可以在上面预订某个时段的会议室，这就是你开会的地方，没错，所以基本上大多数办公室都是这样设置的。说到你的办公桌，我个人一直都用升降桌。帕特里克和我很久以前一起工作过。我们工作的地方需要处理很多机器人和机械设备。所以我总是站着。桌子一直都是站立式的。
And I just kind of got used to it. And I just, yeah, I'm really a big fan of that, actually. I really love standing desks were always standing there and I just kind of got used to it. And, uh, I just, yeah, I'm really a big fan of that. Actually. I really love, uh, standing desks. Um, so what I actually have now, and, and it's just because everyone, it's just now the standard thing is a, is a mechanical desk. So actually like you can hit a button and it'll change from a standing to a sitting desk. Um, they have some really fancy ones where you can have like presets so you can put in your height. And when you hit sitting desk, it'll actually go to a certain setting. I don't really have something that fancy.
我只是习惯了。其实我真的很喜欢升降桌。我真的很喜欢升降桌，它们一直都在那里，我只是习惯了。而且，是的，我真的很喜欢。其实，我真的很喜欢升降桌。所以，我现在实际用的是一种机械升降桌，因为现在这已经成了标配。你可以按一个按钮，它就能在站立和坐姿之间切换。有些非常高级的桌子可以设置预设，你可以输入你的身高。当你按下坐姿按钮时，它会自动调整到特定的高度。我没有那么高级的。
Mine just has you in up and a down. And when you hold the down button, it goes down. Eventually it's down so low it becomes a sitting desk. But yeah, I think standing desks are great i feel like i can focus a lot better when i'm standing um what about you do you do standing or sitting so mine actually is one of those fancy ones so i have presets so i have a preset sitting preset standing and you switch or something um yeah but i find that i fidget a lot more when I stand I think so after a little period of time I get I think I start to get
我的只有上升和下降按钮。当你按住下降按钮时，它就会下降。最后降到很低，就变成了坐姿办公桌。但我觉得升降桌很棒，我觉得站着的时候专注力会好很多。你呢？你是站着还是坐着？我的其实是那种高级的，我有预设，我有坐姿预设和站姿预设，你可以切换之类的。但我发现站着的时候我更容易坐立不安，所以过了一段时间后，我觉得我开始变得
defocused from it but I try to stand but I don't stand as much as I probably should they say sitting kills you I heard that I'm probably dying but I spend most of my day sitting but I try to spend some amount of it standing yeah makes sense
注意力不集中了，但我尽量站着，不过我站的时间可能没达到应该有的程度。人们常说久坐会要了你的命，我听说过，我可能正在慢慢变老，但我大部分时间还是坐着，但我尽量每天站一会儿。是的，有道理。
but then a lot of how your desk ends up looking or or being is whether you've chosen to have a desktop a laptop or both so my current setup is i have a laptop that i take with me to meetings but i mostly work on a desktop and i think for me i like having a desktop because it's even faster and it's sort of in a persistent state and everything. I have just tons of things running and tons of things open and I don't have to worry about it because of a very powerful desktop versus on my laptop. I keep it, you know, sort of a minimal working environment so I can do work, but I'm not for me. I don't do a lot of work remotely, so I'm not really set up to work from my laptop. And I feel like power users is the wrong word, but when I sit at my desktop and I just do it just all the way I want it,
但你的办公桌最终看起来是什么样，或者说是什么配置，取决于你选择用台式机、笔记本电脑还是两者兼有。我目前的配置是，我有一台笔记本电脑，开会时带着，但我大部分时间是在台式机上工作。我觉得我喜欢用台式机，因为它更快，而且处于一种持续运行的状态。我有很多程序在运行，有很多窗口打开，我不用担心，因为台式机性能很强，而笔记本电脑则不同。我让它保持一种极简的工作环境，这样我可以处理工作，但我个人不太常远程办公，所以我的笔记本电脑并没有针对工作进行特别设置。我觉得“重度用户”这个词可能不太准确，但当我坐在台式机前，我可以完全按照我想要的方式操作，
you know, and yeah, everything's set up, everything's running, everything's in, I guess, in warm memory, right? Like all the apps just stay running all the time. So I can just click on them and they're there and I just use them. Yeah, makes sense. I'm a big fan of desktop, but I know a lot of people really love laptops so that they can sort of work at their desk and then pick it up and take it home and just keep working.
你知道，一切都设置好了，一切都在运行，一切都在内存里，对吧？所有的应用程序都一直开着。所以我只需要点击它们，它们就在那里，我直接用就行了。是的，有道理。我很喜欢台式机，但我知道很多人真的很喜欢笔记本电脑，这样他们可以在办公桌前工作，然后带回家继续工作。
Yeah, I mean, in my case, all my development is like these massively parallel programs. And so I can't even really build them on one machine. So even the building of the program is distributed. That's a good point. So they give me a laptop and everything I do is through SSH. I guess if you're connecting to the cloud anyways, it doesn't matter if it's from your desktop or your laptop.
是的，我的情况是，我所有的开发工作都是大规模并行程序。所以我甚至无法在一台机器上构建它们。所以连程序的构建都是分布式的。这是一个很好的观点。所以他们给了我一台笔记本电脑，我所做的一切都是通过SSH连接的。我想如果你反正都要连接到云端，那么是用台式机还是笔记本电脑连接其实都无所谓。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I think you can request a desktop where I work. But I mean, definitely there's people who are building an app or something like that, and they need a desktop. But for me, yeah, it's just everything's on SSH. And so I plug my laptop into my monitor and keyboard when I'm at my desk. But it's just like another different interface. So the other thing, thing too is external monitors.
是的，完全正确。我想在我工作的地方你可以申请台式机。但肯定有人在开发应用程序之类的，他们需要台式机。但对我来说，一切都在SSH上。所以我在办公桌前时，就把笔记本电脑插到显示器和键盘上。但这只是另一种不同的接口。另外还有一点，就是外接显示器。
So kind of getting a lot of screen real estate. I'm personally just, I'm the worst possible example of this. I literally just have one external monitor and I mirror it. So I'm not even using the screen on my laptop. And I'll tell you the reason why it's because i'm constantly kind of going to meetings and and coming back from meetings and whenever i do something like extending my screen it doesn't really gracefully handle when i'm plugging and unplugging um versus you know when i have it mirrored i plug in and everything stays in exactly the same position
为了获得更多的屏幕空间。我个人在这方面是最糟糕的例子。我实际上只有一个外接显示器，而且我把它设置为镜像模式。所以我甚至没有使用笔记本电脑的屏幕。我告诉你原因，因为我经常要去开会，开完会回来，每当我做扩展屏幕这种操作时，插拔的时候它处理得并不顺畅。相比之下，当我使用镜像模式时，插上之后，所有东西都保持在完全相同的位置。
and so then i just you know work on the nice keyboard and mouse but but i have like my mental model hasn't changed at all and then when i unplug the same thing and so i haven't really found like a workflow that is better than that for me but but everyone thinks I'm crazy because I have a screen that's showing the same thing that I'm not looking at. I'm one straw short of the six-monitor day trader. Oh, so you're the opposite. All right, well, this is good. So I have two big monitors,
所以我只需要用好用的键盘和鼠标工作，我的思维模式完全不需要改变，拔掉的时候也是一样。所以我还没找到比这更适合我的工作流程。但每个人都觉得我疯了，因为我有一个屏幕显示着同样的内容，但我却不看它。我离那种拥有六个显示器的日内交易员只差一步之遥。哦，所以你是反过来的。好吧，这很好。我有两个大显示器，
and then I have a third monitor, but the third monitor is plugged into a different computer. So I actually have two full desktop setups on my desktop one okay one machine with keyboard and mouse and monitor and then a second one with two monitors keyboard and mouse and then sometimes i have stuff running on my laptop and so i have my laptop sitting next to me not plugged into any of those monitors so you know i think if i had a desktop you know where uh you know i wouldn't have to unplug and have all the windows go bizarre then i think i think i would have probably two monitors that make use i i've had three monitors before for me for the my flow three is too many i don't
然后我有第三个显示器，但第三个显示器连接到另一台电脑上。所以我实际上在桌面上拥有两套完整的台式机配置。一台机器配有键盘、鼠标和显示器，另一台配有两个显示器、键盘和鼠标。有时我的笔记本电脑上还有东西在运行，所以我把笔记本电脑放在旁边，没有连接到任何显示器上。所以，我想如果我有一台台式机，我就不需要拔掉插头，也不用担心所有窗口都乱跑，我想我可能会用两个显示器。我以前用过三个显示器，但对我来说，三个太多了，我
really need three i have three on my desk now because I have a second desktop for bizarre reasons. But the two monitors are about right because basically I have one monitor in front of me where I sort of have my IDE, my terminal. Yes, I have both. And then in my second monitor, so that one's sort of like straight ahead. So most people put it sort of like the crack in the middle and then the screen symmetric to either side of their head but i actually have one monitor straight ahead and one monitor to the right and and the monitor on the right has like you know my web browser stack overflow uh and uh and then um you know my future source code and my you know my pull requests github stuff whatever you know and then uh split with sort of emailed the you know chat stuff all of that lives on that right screen
并不真的需要三个。我现在桌上有三个，因为出于奇怪的原因我有第二台台式机。但两个显示器刚刚好，因为基本上我面前有一个显示器，上面放着我的IDE和终端。是的，两者都有。然后在第二个显示器上，那个显示器就在正前方。大多数人把显示器放在中间，屏幕对称地分布在头部的两侧，但我实际上是一个显示器在正前方，一个在右边。右边的显示器上有我的网页浏览器、Stack Overflow，还有我未来的源代码、我的GitHub拉取请求之类的。然后分屏放着电子邮件、聊天工具，所有这些都在右边的屏幕上。
and so if i'm doing like email and stuff i'm sort of off facing to the right but if i'm coding and focused i'm like all straight ahead absorbed ah that makes sense yeah i think there was a time i had my laptop, you know, it wasn't mirrored. And that's basically what I did. I had the main screen for like the coding, all of that. And the other screen had the chat and Gmail and all that. Yeah, some people do the second screen
所以如果我在处理邮件之类的，我就面向右边，但如果我在写代码并且很专注，我就面向正前方，完全沉浸其中。啊，有道理。是的，我想有段时间我用笔记本电脑时，它不是镜像模式。那基本上就是我所做的。我用主屏幕写代码，另一个屏幕放聊天工具和Gmail之类的。是的，有些人会用第二个屏幕，
where they rotate the monitor 90 degrees. So it's like tall. Oh yeah, and they can read papers. Yeah, and that's kind of cool. Makes makes sense but it bothers me because it looks weird yeah it looks like an l like a goofy obtuse l so i i have a friend who she um she consults startups for uh recruiting so in other words she she's not a recruiter anymore but she goes to startups and helps them get talent um like an advisor and uh the number one thing she said is she told them to give all their employees the best biggest monitors and uh they say that when candidates come to interview there's just
他们把显示器旋转90度。所以它是竖着的。哦，是的，他们可以阅读文档。是的，这很酷。有道理，但这让我很困扰，因为它看起来很奇怪。是的，它看起来像一个笨拙的钝角L型。我有一个朋友，她为初创公司提供招聘咨询。换句话说，她不再是招聘人员了，但她会去初创公司帮助他们获取人才，就像顾问一样。她说她告诉他们要给所有员工最好、最大的显示器。她说当候选人来面试时，
something it's it's like kind of you know uh conscious kind of subconscious but when people come to interview and they see a bunch of really huge monitors it it massively affects whether they'll take the job or not like they look at it as like oh the company really cares about these people they're giving them huge monitors and i thought it was so bizarre and even you know the lady i was talking to you know it's like an empirical thing you know she didn't really have a you know psychological answer or anything but uh but yeah people are sort of uh uh really valued based on the size of the monitor it becomes like a really important thing so um also at most big companies it's entirely possible to just get whatever sort of keyboard mouse chair setup you want um and when i've been at really big companies they even have like a place you can go to
这是一种潜意识的影响。当人们来面试，看到一堆巨大的显示器时，这会极大地影响他们是否接受这份工作。他们会觉得，哦，这家公司真的很关心员工，给他们配了这么大的显示器。我觉得这太奇怪了。即使是我交谈的那位女士，这更像是一种经验之谈，她并没有什么心理学依据，但人们确实会根据显示器的大小来衡量公司的价值，这成了一件非常重要的事情。此外，在大多数大公司，你完全可以获得任何你想要的键盘、鼠标和椅子配置。当我还在大公司工作时，他们甚至有专门的地方，
and they'll sort of measure you and recommend something for you teach you the right way to sit and how that you're going to die because you sit too much um yeah no they don't say that but they do you get scoliosis um and so so you can sort of get whatever setup you want. And some people have really crazy stuff, like really fancy chairs, keyboards with mechanical switches like Cherry MX Blues that just go... You hear it across the room. And it just gives me cramps thinking about pushing on those keys. They're so hard.
他们会为你测量并推荐适合你的设备，教你正确的坐姿，以及告诉你久坐会让你早死。是的，不，他们不会那样说，但他们会说你会得脊柱侧弯。所以你可以得到任何你想要的配置。有些人有非常疯狂的设备，比如非常高级的椅子，带有Cherry MX青轴那种机械键盘，打字声响彻整个房间。想到要按那些键，我的手指都抽筋了，它们太硬了。
But, you know, people... Yeah, some people like it. Yeah, people just have some people have like really old ibm style keyboards yeah right uh and some people have the kinesis dished keyboards for uh reducing rsi repetitive stress injury yeah people will have really really elaborate setups so you have a vertical mouse that's sort of my speciality i guess is i have a vertical mouse that i really enjoy um for people who don't know a vertical mouse is uh uh you don't have to bend your wrist so in other words like like right now like if you're not driving or something put your
但是，你知道，有些人……是的，有些人喜欢。有些人甚至用那种非常古老的IBM风格键盘。还有些人使用Kinesis碗状键盘来减少重复性劳损（RSI）。是的，人们会有非常复杂的配置。所以你有一个垂直鼠标，我想这是我的专长，我有一个非常喜欢的垂直鼠标。对于不知道的人来说，垂直鼠标就是你不需要弯曲手腕。换句话说，就像现在，如果你没在开车，把你的
hand on the table with your thumb you know the way you'd hold a regular mouse and if you look your your bones are actually crossed over and it doesn't sound like it matters, but instead like hold your arm the way you'd hold like a, you know, a Coke or something, a bottle. And there's actually a mouse that feels like that. It'd be terrible for video games or something like that, but if you don't have to, you know, be that precise or quick quick it actually saves like a ton of stress on your arm so uh yeah so that's that's sort of the only real ergo thing i have um so we can go to like office amenities so what are some of the coolest things you've seen in
手放在桌子上，大拇指朝上，就像你握普通鼠标那样。如果你观察一下，你的骨头实际上是交叉的。这听起来没什么大不了的，但试着像拿可乐瓶那样握住你的手臂。确实有一种鼠标握起来就是那种感觉。它对于玩电子游戏之类的可能很糟糕，但如果你不需要那么精确或快速，它实际上能节省大量手臂压力。所以，是的，这就是我唯一真正的工效学设备。那么，我们可以聊聊办公室设施，你见过最酷的东西是什么？
offices either that you've worked at visited you know heard about rumored about the moon base so so well okay a lot of offices have some way to get food easily so you know because think about it like you're working sometimes you pull crazy hours especially if you're coding you a lot of coding jobs a lot of software engineering jobs have kind of an ebb and flow. And so when you're really in a grind, you know, you want to be able to get some food, you don't have to go 12, 14 hours. So most places will have like a convenient way for you to eat. Hopefully, it's even just like, it's just like ubiquitous food. I mean, it doesn't have to be anything fancy, it could be just like a stash of granola bars or something but most offices will like hit up a costco or
在办公室里，无论是你工作过的、参观过的，还是听说过的，甚至是关于月球基地的传闻。好吧，很多办公室都有方便获取食物的方式。因为你想想，有时候你工作时间很长，尤其是如果你在写代码。很多编程工作、软件工程工作都有起伏。所以当你处于高强度工作时，你希望能够吃到东西，而不必坚持12到14个小时。所以大多数地方都会有方便你进食的方式。希望它甚至只是随处可见的食物。我的意思是，不需要什么高级的东西，可能只是一堆燕麦棒之类的。但大多数办公室会每隔一两周去一次Costco，
something every week or two and and there'll be you know kind of a place to eat um some other kind of cool amenities some places will have a gym where you could go and work out especially if you need to uh think about something sometimes it's good to like go for a run or even go for a walk around the building type thing um a lot of places will have a game room so it could be some ping pong or xbox or something like that um as a way to sort of decompress right um some other kind of more esoteric things uh are like nap pods so for people who haven't seen this um it's actually i don't even know how to describe it okay so it's like a chair but the chair is you know tilted back so you're lying down in this chair and then there's this dome and uh the dome just goes over your head
然后会有一个地方可以吃东西。还有一些其他很酷的设施，有些地方有健身房，你可以去锻炼，特别是如果你需要思考问题的时候。有时候去跑步，或者在楼里散散步之类的都很好。很多地方会有游戏室，可以打乒乓球、玩Xbox之类的，作为一种放松的方式。还有一些更深奥的东西，比如睡眠舱。对于没见过的人，我甚至不知道该怎么描述它。它就像一把椅子，但椅子是向后倾斜的，所以你躺在这把椅子里，然后有一个圆顶罩住你的头。
and it's not like playing it's like it's kind of like imax like an imax just for you except it's not playing any video it's just it's just a black dome that goes over your head and so it you know kind of completely takes away you know the outside stimulus and so you can just kind of uh in theory you can sleep i think it's kind of weird to sleep like right there where everyone's you know working um but in theory you could do it but it's really a way to just kind of rest your eyes and and chill for a bit um there's also quiet rooms these also be called prayer rooms um you know a lot of places have that and uh i have to kind of confess so when uh my son was really young um i actually didn't take my paternity leave
它不像是在播放视频，有点像IMAX，但只是为你一个人准备的。除了它不播放任何视频，只是一个罩在你头上的黑色圆顶。所以它完全隔绝了外界的刺激，理论上你可以睡觉。我觉得在每个人都在工作的地方睡觉有点奇怪，但理论上你可以这样做。但这确实是一种让你闭目养神、放松一下的方式。还有安静室，有时也叫祈祷室。很多地方都有。我得坦白一下，当我儿子还很小的时候，我实际上没有休陪产假。
there's like a period of time in between when he was born and when't take my paternity leave there's like a period of time in between when he was born and when i started my paternity leave and it's kind of strategic um because i had parents in town that were helping and stuff like that but you know we had a newborn like just born and uh there's definitely a couple of times around that time where I slept in the quiet room for probably like an hour. And so I'm going to tell your boss. Yeah. Yeah. If my boss, uh, uh, is watching the podcast, well, you can't fire me cause I don't work there anymore, but that happened. Um, uh, but yeah, so in general, you know, quiet room is a good place, or if you, if you're really just exhausted, you could take a nap before driving home or something like that um those are the big sort of office amenities that i remember some things people have at their desks like did you ever work somewhere where people had sent on exercise
在他出生和我开始休陪产假之间有一段时间，这有点策略性，因为我有父母在城里帮忙。但我们有一个刚出生的婴儿，在那段时间里，我确实有几次在安静室里睡了大概一个小时。我要去告诉你的老板。是的，如果我的老板在看这个播客，好吧，你不能解雇我，因为我不在那里工作了，但那确实发生了。但总的来说，安静室是个好地方，或者如果你真的精疲力竭，可以在开车回家前小睡一会儿。这些是我记得的大型办公室设施。人们在桌子上放的一些东西，你有没有在人们使用健身球的地方工作过？
balls i think standing desks sort of replaced this but yeah that's true i feel like this was a thing a while ago yeah like it's uh i don't know if this has even been parodied because i think it's one of these things that if people saw it they just wouldn't even know what to think but yeah there's people who i'm not insulting these people in any way but it's just like it's an interesting thing to see like there's people who just yeah sit on an exercise ball literally all day and the idea is you you're you're sort of wobbling a little and your core kind of gets an exercise so it's better than just kind of sitting around yeah i did sit on an exercise ball for a while i used to have one at my desk a chair and an
我觉得升降桌已经取代了这个，但确实，我觉得这在以前很流行。我不知道这是否被恶搞过，因为我觉得如果人们看到它，他们甚至不知道该怎么想。但确实有人，我绝不是在侮辱这些人，但这确实是一个有趣的现象。有些人整天坐在健身球上，想法是你一直在轻微晃动，你的核心肌群得到了锻炼，所以这比单纯坐着要好。是的，我确实坐过一段时间健身球，我以前在办公桌前有一个椅子和一个
exercise ball um until someone took it i don't know where it went someone took your well so i showed up when i first started working and someone had left one. And so I used it. And then one day mine disappeared. So maybe the person came back and took it. Oh, I see. But anyway, so I had one. It actually, you know, I couldn't do it for long periods of time, but it's kind of nice. If you're just like answering email or doing something that's not super focused, just sort of like bounce around a little. I kind of liked it.
健身球，直到有人把它拿走了。我不知道它去哪了。有人拿走了你的……好吧，我刚开始工作时，有人留下了一个。所以我用了它。然后有一天我的不见了。也许那个人回来把它拿走了。哦，我明白了。但不管怎样，我有一个。它实际上……我不能长时间使用它，但如果你只是在回复邮件或做一些不需要高度专注的事情，稍微弹跳一下还是挺好的。我挺喜欢的。
I'm not going to lie. It looked goofy, but it was kind of fun. I'll have to see if I can find one somewhere in the office. They have also the exercise ball chair, which I think is not the same thing. Oh, wait. I don't know what that is. That is where literally it's a chair. So the exercise ball is pinned.
我不撒谎，它看起来很滑稽，但挺有趣的。我得看看能不能在办公室里再找一个。他们还有健身球椅，我觉得那不是一回事。哦，等等，我不知道那是什么。那就是字面意义上的椅子。所以健身球被固定住了。
It can't move. But you're just getting the cushion of an exercise ball. But you're not really doing any of the workout. Whoa, I see this. Whoa. Yeah, isn't that crazy? I saw one the other day. I was like, what is this?
它不能动。但你只是得到了健身球的缓冲感。但你并没有真正进行任何锻炼。哇，我看到了。哇，是的，这不疯狂吗？我前几天看到了一个。我当时想，这是什么？
This is cool. I kind of want one of these. All right, you check it out. I'm going to contact my ergonomics department and tell them I need one of these. You need a chair. So I don't think I've uh typically in like a communal space although i did one time see a person who had one at their actual desk is a treadmill desk where you have a standing desk and then a treadmill underneath it and so you have to walk while you type now i do not know how this works if you're
这很酷。我想要一个这样的。好吧，你去看看。我要联系我的工效学部门，告诉他们我需要一个这个。你需要一把椅子。所以我不认为我通常在公共空间见过，虽然我有一次看到一个人在他们的办公桌前用跑步机办公桌，你有一个升降桌，下面有一个跑步机，你必须边走边打字。现在我不知道如果你在
doing like video conferencing or doing training videos or watching youtube videos uh twitch i mean not totally working sure but i feel like if i'm programming i get seasick like moving moving my head as i walk and like trying to type i know like i don't get it i mean people do it and i don't knock them it's great i wish i could exercise that much but like you know i have seen this though desks where it's like a tall standing desk and then just basically like a treadmill underneath yeah i know a guy at work and i'll call him mike his name is mike um and so mike if you're if you're listening to this is someone i used to work with and yeah as you said he probably spent three hours a day on the treadmill and he got a lot done so this isn't knocking him at all but yeah like the idea of trying to walk and write code at the same time, it just boggles my mind.
进行视频会议、看培训视频或看YouTube、Twitch时，这怎么运作。我的意思是，不是完全在工作，但我感觉如果我在编程，我会晕船，因为我走路时头在动，还要尝试打字。我知道，我不明白。我的意思是人们确实这样做，我并不贬低他们，这很棒。我希望我能锻炼那么多，但我确实见过这种桌子，是一个高高的升降桌，下面基本上就是一个跑步机。是的，我认识一个同事，我叫他迈克，他的名字是迈克。所以迈克，如果你在听这个，这是我以前的同事。正如你所说，他可能每天在跑步机上花三个小时，他完成了很多工作。所以这并不是在贬低他，但边走边写代码的想法，确实让我感到不可思议。
Some other kind of novelty things. Some companies do free massages. Some companies have a valet service, so you don't have to find a place to park in the parking lot. You just get to work and hand over your keys um even crazier there's some valets that'll like uh refuel your car so if an electric car they'll make sure all the cars are charged yeah they'll just uh i guess like a tanker truck drives by a small tanker truck and just fills all i don't know it's bizarre um some other really novelty things uh there's some people who take an airplane to work um I know somebody who uh and you know like this is something you would hear
还有一些其他的新奇事物。有些公司提供免费按摩。有些公司有代客泊车服务，所以你不必在停车场找车位。你上班时直接把钥匙交给他们。甚至更疯狂的是，有些代客泊车服务会帮你加油。如果是电动车，他们会确保所有车都充好电。是的，我想会有一辆油罐车开过来，一辆小型油罐车，把所有车都加满。我不知道，这很奇怪。还有一些其他非常新奇的事情，有些人坐飞机去上班。我认识一个人，你知道，这就像你会听到的
about like someone takes an airplane to go to the alps to rescue someone or something or goes to Yukon uh or something like that but this is yeah, normal people would just take a small biplane to work. Or a ferry, you know, we live in Silicon Valley. So there's a, I don't know if it's still running. But there was a ferry that was taking people from, you know, East Bay, across the bay, to South Bay to various companies. Well, in New York City, people take the ferry to work like that's pretty common. I think actually, yeah, there isn't that novelty yeah that's true i can think actually a lot of people do that that's okay though yeah but here it is kind of it's different so yeah i mean well we have such a traffic nightmare here that and we didn't even cover all the sort of things about that's okay it's not really part of office spaces but all of the nice things that we as sort of
关于某人坐飞机去阿尔卑斯山营救某人，或者去育空地区之类的。但这是正常的，人们只是坐小型双翼飞机去上班。或者渡轮，你知道，我们住在硅谷。所以有一个，我不知道它是否还在运行。但曾经有一艘渡轮载着人们从东湾穿过海湾，到南湾的各个公司。好吧，在纽约市，人们坐渡轮上班，这很常见。我想实际上，是的，这并不新奇。是的，那确实是真的，我想很多人确实那样做。那没关系。是的，但在这里，情况不同。所以，我的意思是，我们这里的交通简直是噩梦，我们甚至没有涵盖所有关于……没关系，这不是办公室空间的一部分，但我们作为编程领域工作的人所享受的所有美好事物，有时我确实觉得我把它视为理所当然，忘记了我们有健康保险。好吧，我想这取决于你是否住在美国，但，你知道，有健康保险、退休账户缴款、带薪实习。有很多东西，你知道，在某种程度上是设施，我想，是的，绝对是。但我不是超级粉丝，我从来没有，即使我工作过的地方被认为有非常好的办公室，我也从来没有真正印象深刻。我觉得我在这里的办公桌前能更有效率，
working in the programming field, you know, I feel like sometimes I take for granted and forget that we get health insurance. And well, I guess it depends on if you're living in the United States or not, but, um, you know, get health insurance, retirement account contributions, like paid internships. There's lots of things that, know are sort of amenities i guess in some way that uh yeah yeah absolutely but yeah i'm not a super big fan i've never been even i have worked at places that have been considered to have really good offices and i've never really been super impressed that like i feel like i can be so much more productive here as far as like at my desk the
外围的东西确实很好，但我觉得即使它在隔壁楼里，效果也一样。是的，完全正确。唯一我认为有区别的是食物情况，唯一的原因是因为它有助于建立同志情谊。是的，就像，如果你在设计一个让人们成为软件工程师的地方，我会想设计成一种人们被迫，或者不是被迫，显然，而是被激励去社交的方式。所以有一个每个人都去吃饭的地方是一个很好的方式。还有游戏室，如果你有一个房间里装满了Xbox和一堆其他游戏，那么第一件事
peripheral stuff is really nice but i feel like it could be in the building next to me and be just as effective yeah yeah exactly the only thing that uh i think makes a difference is um the food situation and the only reason is because it helps to like build uh the camaraderie like basically fair yeah like i've been like you want to be in a way like i would say you know if i was designing a place for for people to be software engineers i'd want to design in a way where people were forced to like kind of socialize together or not forced obviously but like incentivized and so the like having one place where everyone goes to eat is a kind of really good way to do that um also the the game room so if you have you know one room just like stocked with like xbox and a bunch of other games then it kind of like the first thing
当设置好那个房间时，人们会在别人玩的时候出现，然后离开，他们会为了Xbox产生争夺。但很快人们就会意识到，哦，你们应该一起玩，这样我们就不用争了。有人可以直接加入游戏，而不是离开。所以它确实强迫了一些同志情谊和社交。好吧，这就是这次节目的全部内容。是的，有很多疯狂的配置，你可以上网看看。BusinessInsider.com以报道这些而闻名，比如“看看LinkedIn新的旧金山办公室，你可以从摩天大楼上滑翔伞”。
that'll happen when you set that up is people will kind of show up when someone else is playing and then leave and they'll kind of be like contention for the xbox but then you know people pretty quickly realize oh well you should just all play together and then we don't have to have contention like someone could just jump into the game and instead of leaving right and so it kind of forces some like camaraderie and some socialization well that's all you got for this time yeah that's that's uh that's there's been a whole bunch of crazy setups you can go online businessinsider.com is famous for talking about like oh check out you know linkedin's new san francisco office where you can you know paraglide
这些疯狂的事情。但总的来说，我认为我们涵盖了基础知识以及它们为什么重要。如果你有一个疯狂的办公室配置，给我们发邮件。我们很想听听。如果你在驾驶超音速喷气机时编程，那太棒了。给我们发张照片。编程、飞行和自拍。
off the skyscraper, like these crazy things. But in general, I think we covered kind of the basics and sort of why they're important. If you have a crazy office setup, send us an email. We'd love to hear it. If you program while you're flying a supersonic jet or something, that would be amazing. Send us a picture. Programming, flying, and taking a selfie.
杰森，这是有限度的。是的，我不认为，不要因为撞毁飞机之类的而上新闻。那会很糟糕。但如果你能完成一张自拍，那就做吧。哦，天哪。哦，伙计。再次感谢你们的支持。希望你们喜欢这一集。是的，这不是
There are limits, Jason. Yeah, I don't think, yeah, don't end up in the news for, you know, crashing an airplane or something. That would be bad. But if you could pull off a selfie, do it. Oh, dear. Oh, man. So thanks a lot again for your support. I hope you enjoyed this episode yes this isn't
关于编程语言或对编程语言发明者的采访之类的。这是一个离题的话题，我们在邮件中被问到过，所以我们认为这会是一个有趣的节目。所以，给我们发邮件，让我们知道你的想法，因为有很多像这样的话题，你是否喜欢它将真正决定我们谈论什么。所以，好吧，下次见，再见。片头音乐是Biner Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
about a coding language or an interview with a coding language inventor or anything like that um it's kind of an off the wall thing we were asked in an email about it and so we thought it'd make a fun episode uh so yeah send us an email let us know what you think because you know there's a lot of topics like this and uh you know whether you like it or not will really determine what we talked about so all right till next time see you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于编程语言或对编程语言发明者的采访之类的，这有点出人意料。我们是在一封电子邮件中被问到这个问题的，所以我们觉得这会是一期有趣的节目。所以，是的，给我们发邮件，让我们知道你的想法，因为你知道有很多类似的话题，而且你是否喜欢它将真正决定我们谈论的内容。好了，下次见，再见。片头音乐是Biner Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，也可以进行重混和改编，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。